this is jocko podcast number 251 with
echo charles and me
jocko willink good evening echo good
evening
and also joining us tonight
is my brother leif babin from podcast 11
first guest ever on the podcast 34
65 114 and 138
and obviously leif was in task unit
bruiser as the charlie platoon commander
in the battle ramadi we wrote extreme
ownership we wrote the dichotomy of
leadership together
and we have a leadership consultancy
called echelon front
[Music]
and i at one point in my life gave
him the book that i've been reviewing
for the last couple episodes
that i wrote the new forward to the book
is called
about face and we're going to talk a
little bit about that but then we're
going somewhere else
life thanks for coming back on man
thanks for the time you're 2018
14 august 2018 the world has changed
drastically since then that's
that's that's kind of crazy it's crazy
that
as much as i see you we just didn't
coordinate for another podcast
in over two years
that's uh apparently uh did you say
everything you had to say on the first
five
apparently so that's just the way it is
uh you were telling me about
about face in the battle of ramadi
me kinda saying hey check this out
check out this check out this section
what were you thinking i'm reading you
about like
the south vietnamese army and how
corrupt they were or
whatever like all these different
examples yeah i mean just i thought it
was
so awesome that this new you know this
new book with the new ford written by
you you know for about face the
the new the new version of it that's out
with the new ford and uh
i remember distinctly coming back from
operations in in ramadi
multiple times probably at least four or
five different times i could remember
where i like walk into uh the your
office in the tackle operation center at
the camp margulie and you'd say
hey listen to this and i was like okay
and you bust out the book
you'd open it up to like a highlighted
section read the section
and it was mind-blowing because it was
just like
it was written about the operation that
i was just on like an hour ago
and instead it was written 40 years
before about vietnam
uh and and it was it was pretty pretty
eerie and that was
it had i never realized all the
influences until later when you gave me
a copy of the book
um which is the one thing that you gave
to me and you gave to cesto and
the del platoon commander when we when
we finished asking a bruiser we came
home
i still have that book it's dated you
know january 2007 we've just been home
for
two months at that point but uh now
going through that book i realized like
where you got
you know renaming tasking a bruiser uh
you know all those things like there was
so many things that came from that so it
had
so much influence on you and through you
on me and
and everybody interested the bruiser and
then every generation afterward
that's crazy uh now
in that book in the book about face
there's two quotes that always
bothered me here's the first one
men in battle men will do in battle
what they have been in the habit of
doing in training
general bruce clark one of the us army's
greatest training generals
had written in his then recently
published
guidelines for the leader and commander
so that's the first quote that bothered
me the second quote that bothered me was
this
quote the troops responded well to hard
hands-on repetitive but still
interesting work
they may not have wanted to go to
vietnam but they sure as hell didn't
want to die there
so they even flocked to off-duty classes
like recondo meanwhile i established the
requirement that all
officers and ncos in the battalion
read and carry on their person
general bruce clark's guidelines for the
leader and commander
as far as i was concerned the finest
little handbook on leadership and
training
ever written and adopt as their own
philosophy
the one that i'd learned from a five by
seven
card which i still had issued to me in
clark's seventh army in
germany which stated an organization
does well
only those things the boss checks end
quote
so why did those two quotes bothered me
they didn't bother me because i didn't
agree with them
obviously they bothered me because i
could never
find this specific book called
guidelines for the leader in commander
and i always searched for it
i would look for and you know these days
you can pretty much find
anything online especially like a lot of
the old manuals that i read
old army manuals on you know they've
been out of print for a long time but
you can go find a pdf somebody uploaded
it this thing has been nowhere forever
and here i was learning from this book
that colonel hackworth wrote but i could
never find the book that
hackworth learned from and that did not
make me happy
so so who was this guy general bruce
crock
bruce clark he was in world war one
world war ii korea he enlisted in 1917
ended up going to west point hopefully
you don't hold that against him
life good to go i i turned down my
appointment to west point but uh it's a
it's a great place you got into private
army school look at you overachiever
[Music]
i had to go i had to go to the seal the
seal route man
you that's a rough gamble
right it was a rough gamble and it paid
it was very poor
gamble when i graduated and i didn't get
selected for the seal program i could
tell you i was like
i should have gone to west point i'd be
in the army um you know i'd have all
these opportunities in front of me
that is the that is the that is the
worst
luck that the it happens that the seal
teams
is in the navy and if you don't if you
want to be a seal and you don't make it
into the seal teams
you're in the navy because you probably
don't want to have the type of job that
a regular navy dude has
if you want to be in the sealed teams
would you concur definitely
i mean if you if you want to be in the
seal teams that means you want to be
shooting a machine gun and running
around
in the streets or the jungle or whatever
you don't want to be on a ship
you know working in an engine room or or
you know driving a ship standing on a
bridge
watch or whatever and those are cool
jobs too for different people like
different jobs
but those are two almost totally
different types of jobs
whereas hey if you tried for special
forces and you didn't make it you'd
still be an infantry guy and that's
still the
similar thing but you just rolled the
dice big time
i did but it uh it worked out then you
know you got to trust
in fact had i gotten selected for the
seal program right out of the academy in
1998 when i graduated
i'd have never been a tasking bruiser i
would have not been charlie platoon
commander
i would have done my oic probably at
least
a year or two or three prior to that as
a lot of the guys who were my same year
group
um so you know that's uh the good lord
has a plan and you gotta just trust in
that plan and uh
had i actually not had i got selected
from marine corps i obviously never had
a chance to be in the seal teams either
so
um look west point's an awesome school
man it was a really
really agonizing decision for me because
i got i got picked up for west point
in uh in in like it was like probably
january february of my senior year and
then i
found out i got i got an appointment so
i accepted it and then i didn't find out
until like april that i got into the
navy
so it was uh you know it was it was a it
was a big gamble for sure but
hey man it's a it's an awesome uh
obviously there's a great rival between
west point and you know army navy
everybody knows the football games and
but uh
i am one of the the things we're most
proud of obviously in tasking bruiser
was being the
the 1-1 a.d army seals as they call this
and uh so good on general clark one
thing that that i
just wanted to say when you read that
quote i'm fascinated
you know to to listen this as well
because i have used that quote
an organization does well only those
things the boss checks probably a
thousand times
since teaching the junior officer
training course up through what we do
now with echelon fraud
and i did not realize it came out of
this book i was gonna say don't you
usually attribute it to me i was
attributed to hackers
yeah i think i just misremembered that
he he obviously was giving credit
to general clark and i clearly did not
remember that and i've not done that
right yeah uh
so he went to west point so enlisted
world war one went to west point world
war ii commanded the fourth
armored division in patents patent's
third army
battle of era court battle the bulge
distinguished service cross and three
silver stars
also in korea ended up with 45 or so
years of service
uh not only leading troops
but also he oversaw a bunch of training
schools and training commands
died in 1988 at age 86 and i wanted this
book i searched for this book for years
i i wrote an email to the publisher this
publisher
still exists i'm going to call him out
right now because i'm sure someone will
reach out to them i think it's stackpole
books they still exist
and we've covered other books of theirs
on this podcast because they
print a lot of military type books i
think the clay pigeons of saint lo
we covered that on this podcast and a
few others that are in the queue
i reached out to him sent an email hey
i'm looking for this book i see that you
used to publish it
nothing never heard nothing back um
and then you know like you said the lord
works mysterious ways
the about face the new the new version
comes out and i
search on on amazon once a month i'll
search and see
because they they would have this book
they'd have it listed in there that's
how i knew the publisher was
but they would have it in there and not
available not available not available
for years it's been not available
it popped up it says available one copy
three hundred dollars bro three hundred
dollars
this is and i'm i'm only holding a
photocopy right now it was three hundred
dollars this thing is 117 pages it's
like uh
i don't know six by 11 or it's small
it's this little book it showed up in a
little tiny envelope
i was super stoked and um
as you might imagine like you said it's
filled with lessons filled with the
obvious roots of hack worse
theories around training and leadership
which i stole
as you already rightfully accused me of
stealing
many things from hackworth as i fully
admit all the time
that i stole i used passed on to
everyone i could still try and pass on
still trying to pass on and about faith
still trying to pass and what we do at
echelon front try and pass on these
lessons
so you know what i don't think you can
actually use the word steel because
they're freely given
in the same way that like when people
are like hey do you mind if we like
talk about extreme ownership with our
team like no i actually don't mind in
fact that's what we wrote the book for
that's why hack i'm sure that's why hack
wrote the about face
and i'm sure obviously that's why
general clark wrote what he wrote so
um it's not stealing it's freely given
and i think uh
the as we we have often said that we
didn't learn anything new we just
we just maybe package it a little bit
differently yeah or use a different term
than maybe others use it's always good
when um
it's pretty common for you know
me to do a an initial client call with a
company
and they'll be you know give me a brief
on their company and they're like our
company values are
blah blah blah blah blah extreme
ownership and they're like
hey we hope you don't mind we're like
the exact same thing i say you can't
steal what's free so
uh and i try and give hackworth credit
yeah but i guess you're right can't
steal
what's free but what we can do is we can
take it and we can try and pass it on
so without further ado i present to you
at long last
guidelines for the leader and commander
there's i'll have to show it to you uh
later there's a little there's a little
signature i don't have it in the
photocopy there's
it's written there's a little you know
somebody gave it to someone someone gave
it to like the command sergeant major or
something like that
all right so here we go dedicated to
the ground combat soldier the paramount
concern of the army is the ground combat
soldier
he is the focal point of all our efforts
organizing equipping
training sustaining and supporting him
so that he can perform his
indispensable role in combat
is the army role the role is equally
significant in
any kind of war hot or cold
it is just as important in general war
as it is in limited war
for our nation to entertain any notion
to the contrary
would be dangerous the danger
could be social as well as military
more than any other category of
personnel in the armed forces the ground
combat soldier comes from the general
populace
he is the private citizen under arms the
clenched
fist of his people
that's i think i'm just rolling with
that from now on that is uh
the greatest description of combat yes
of a combat soldier i've ever heard in
my life the clenched fist of the people
why why is this the first time i'm
hearing this that's the one thing i'm uh
i'm just remiss about yeah that's what
i'm saying me too
we could have uh we could have put that
up as like a poster for tasking a
bruiser
you know i think i think i
used and you may have heard me use this
in fact i know you did uh
the sword of destruction uh i use that
to describe
sort of what our methodology was
especially in cleaning out insurgents
and how hey everyone wants to be
everyone wants to make
friends and and win the hearts and minds
and that's all definitely important
but that really comes and this is this
is when i use this line
that would come after the sword of
destruction has been
wielded on the insurgents or the bad
guys
i think the fist of the people is better
we're going with it clenched fist
the clenched fist of the people back to
the book it is by no
idle chance in the history of mankind
that the course of democracy
parallels the importance accorded to the
ground combat soldier in the military
forces of
nations it is no exaggeration to say
that the basic
freedoms we now enjoy are closely
related to his ascending
importance on the battlefields since the
battle of
crazy nor is it an exaggeration in my
opinion
to say that the preservation of those
freedoms will continue
to be oriented by his place in the sun
only when men from all of the people
are willing and ready to fight and die
for freedom
does freedom have meaning for them
only then does democracy thrive
that is the inexorable lesson of history
these are important things to be reading
right around this time in the world
because what percentage of of the
populace actually is in the military one
percent
so there's not a lot of people that seem
to step up and be ready and willing and
what does that mean that means they
don't understand what the price is they
understand what the cost is what he's
saying here is
freedom is only safe when there's people
that are when there's
all people he's saying all people by the
way all people have to be ready and
willing
it's heavy well you also have to think
about his perspective though
right i mean i i think in america today
obviously we've been at war for a long
time since 9 11 and
but there really there isn't an
existential threat in the way that
would he was living with world war one
you've got this expanding empire now
world war ii you've got
you've got the the japanese and germans
i mean there's
the world was truly at stake and uh and
it was
everybody all hands on deck even those
that couldn't serve
who weren't medically qualified or
whatever like
they're they're you know they're they're
doing uh uh
everything from blood drives to you know
uh collecting tires
all that kind of stuff is going on back
here bond drives you know liberty
gardens
yeah uh you know the the rosie the
riveter i mean ladies out there turning
wrenches and building planes and
tanks and all that stuff so i think that
was i i mean our country hasn't
experienced that
probably since since world war ii but i
think living through that probably gave
him
unique perspective
this also ties in continuing on beguiled
by the mechanical marvels of an age
it is easy for people to forget the true
character of the ground combat soldiers
in war when free men have been
so beguiled in the past they have
slipped back into slavery
for the ability of the ground combat
soldier to play his part in the social
scheme of things depends
upon the part he has given in the
military scheme of things
again we we can very easily
think about the fact that you know this
war is a technical thing and you don't
have to
have to put boots on the ground and that
whole idea
that technology can eliminate war
and you and i were talking the other day
that there's there's some people that
hey god bless them they have a positive
attitude that
we as a species can evolve to a point
where you know we don't have war anymore
and that's
a very positive thought i think we would
all agree that that would be a great
thing
it's probably highly unrealistic because
there's always going to be somebody
no matter how nice you are there's
always going to be somebody that's going
to try and
take a couple extra dollars from you
echo charles yes sir you have to defend
yourself
i understand even if you're super nice
yes you might have to fight i understand
i don't think
you can't study history and believe that
we're on some greater trajectory and
mankind is above war or conflict or evil
or darkness and uh the thing i love most
about this podcast
is reminding people of the darkness you
can't appreciate the light if you don't
know the darkness and uh
and i think that's that's the most
powerful thing and i think only if you
experience what general clark has
experienced do you do you fully get and
understand that
i i answered a question on the podcast a
long time ago a guy said you know
you keep talking about training jiu
jitsu but i don't even like to fight
why should i train jiu jitsu and i said
if you don't like to fight you are
actually the premier person that needs
to train jiu jitsu
and if you don't like war and you don't
want to go to war
then you should train and prepare and be
ready to go to war
and then hopefully you won't have to and
if you do it'll be swift
the other thing that that quote reminds
me of is that
we get asked how often do we get asked
about you know talk about some training
or bud story you know from the
seal basic training program and we don't
even talk about that stuff because i
think people
i mean the the i i'm trying to explain
to people that the the the
physical nature of combat operations is
so much more you know more difficult
than anything in training
and then then the emotional you know i
was going to suspect that as a physical
yes but
the mental and emotional isn't even
comparable thing
right like it's not a comparable thing
to say well you know
i was really wet and cold during seal
training
compared to i was waiting to suck start
an
ied 17 nights in a row
you know like that's definitely more
mental stress
than hey you're gonna have to go hit the
surf again who cares
no question about that but what i'm
talking about the physical nature of it
so we're talking about the ground combat
soaker here
and this is you know i'm thinking about
you know
one of our seals i mean you certainly
know him well one of my most awesome
guys in charlotte platoon
super just a physical you know stud
awesome dude
who's like going down with heat
exhaustion and like can't can't continue
forward
and i'm having like give me your machine
gun
take my you know my rifle my m4
we gotta move man we can't stay here
we're gonna get we're gonna get hammered
you know we knew we were gonna get we're
gonna get uh ambushed at any second so
it was uh just the physical nature of
that like i can't
physically continue because i'm carrying
you know
80 pounds of gear on this patrol and
it's 117 degrees right now
and i got a little behind the hydration
curve uh because we've been out here for
48 hours doing this kind of stuff and
i'm going down
with heat exhaustion you know so i think
that's something that people
when you're talking about technology and
or riding in vehicles or flying an
aircraft or shooting missiles and
there's there's just no getting around
the the guys carrying
a rucksack you know a heavy rucksack
with gear
and going on foot and ramadi was unique
like that for us because
if you drove into those areas you were
gonna get blowed up
and uh it was it was a good reminder of
the physical nature of uh of war and i
think you know
what he's talking about with the ground
combat soldier is
is exactly right it's just it's just
savage
like it's just you know when you
whenever you put on
you know like at the beginning of land
warfare training and you haven't put on
a rucksack in whatever two months
because you were
coming back from deployment and then you
go on leave and whatever
and you get out to the desert warfare
training facility
and you put your gear on for the first
time and you're like yeah
the first it's one of those things where
the first like 20 minutes
you're just thinking this completely
sucks and then it just sucks so bad that
the suck kind of numbs out
but it's just savage it's just it just
it's just a constant level of pain and
no matter how good of shape you thought
you were i mean that guy was just
talking about was in awesome shape he
was a great you know
physical specimen like awesome dude
trained hard all the time one of the
best seals i know
uh i mean it happened to me i remember
johnny kim
was putting into position johnny kim was
like you know here's our corpsman
he was like hey uh leif you doing okay
i'm like uh i don't know matt you know
he's i was like super pale and he could
see that i was
and i i just i was dehydrated and we're
already smoked we've been up for 24
hours
so he like gave me an iv and you know to
just help me help me recuperate it's
and we were in good shape i mean we
trained hard we were already
acclimatized it's just
it was it was hard it was physically
difficult all those emotional things are
absolutely the case
but it was a phys it was physically hard
um
and probably the best dave burke talks
about this see you guys
good deal dave burke um running with a
pallet
of water between where you you were back
at cop falcon we were in a cyber
overwatch position like
300 yards down the street carrying uh on
an israeli stretcher with like
pallets of water and mres which probably
you know probably weighed like 200
pounds
and running as fast as we could with
that in all our combat gear for 300
yards
dave dave burke was just he was like
hey we're like let's go and we're just
running and
uh it was it was awesome i did a
delivery run to you guys down there
you did yeah you brought some water too
because we were just we were just baking
on the rooftop and nothing
yeah like even just that even just
sitting there baking on a rooftop for
three days
just just getting dehydrated as
everything sucks as to cro to quote tony
everything sucks everything's nothing
worse
all right back to the book it will be a
sorry day for all mankind
in this supersonic nuclear age
of ours should the ground combat soldier
ever be deprived of his rightful place
in the hearts and minds
and military forces of his people
in our efforts to avoid this danger
a one army attitude must pervade all
ranks the ground combat soldier
is not a guardsman nor a regular nor
reservist
nor a selectee he is simply the american
fighting man
on the one army team
i appeal to every member of the team
civilian
and military to give his cause the
enthusiastic
support merited by its vital importance
to our country bruce c
clarke general u.s army
there's the intro we're already off to a
good start
i'm uh the next copy that's up for 300
bucks
uh i got to figure out what i'm gonna do
i'm sure stackpool will will reach out
but if they don't i'm just going to
publish this thing jacob
publishes coming in hot with the pdf
publishers forward these guidelines were
written by a leader and commander
out of the wealth of experience gained
by him in leading and commanding troops
from a squad to an
army group these guidelines were
prepared for the benefit of the
of other leaders and commanders in the
us army in order that they
in turn may make use of his counsel and
experience so as you said
he wrote this for us general bruce c
clarke has probably had more command
duty at more command levels than any
other
officer in the u.s army living or dead
he served more than 40 years in all
grades from private to four star general
known as the most effective trainer of
modern times
in the u.s army as well as an
outstanding combat commander
general clark here specifies the methods
he has used with outstanding success
in management training in soldier
management
and in leadership and generalship
what do you think not exactly a
lightweight not exactly a lightweight
and there's a picture in here says the
ground combat soldier the focal
point of all our efforts you know what's
cool god well i was just
as you're saying that you know i'm i'm
sitting here i'm thinking about my
experience in ramadi and you know our
combat experience three deployments in
iraq
is just absolutely nothing compared to
what
someone who fought in world war one
world war ii and korea
i mean it's it's just it just i'm so
humble when i read about people's
experiences
and realize oh i if i think i thought i
thought i saw some combat and
oh that was significant for the iraq
wars like man it's absolutely nothing
all the
even the physical hardships i'm
describing just
pale in comparison you know to to
battles and and
just what what general clark experience
and so many have experienced throughout
the
yeah the ages we often uh
joke about the fact that
just what we experienced compared to
what these guys went through
when we had dean ladd on the podcast who
got
gut shot rolling into tarawa
500 yards from the beach there's no
possible way he should survive that and
by the way
what was really crazy is that was like
he did
after he got done with that he had
already done one of the other islands
he goes into tarou gets gut shot two of
the marines disobey all orders and
actually grab him and bring him back to
a boat he gets
somehow miraculously safe he goes back
to hawaii and then
six months later he's back going on
another island campaign it's like oh you
got gotcha but you survived it's cool
you're in the game yeah
america what
all right chapter one part one is
leadership and command
chapter one command responsibilities
introduction when an individual assumes
command of a unit large or small
he steps into one of the most
interesting and the most challenging
assignments a member of the armed forces
can have
here is a job into which a man can sink
his teeth
here is a job where initiative
originality
hard work fidelity and human
understanding can pay off in the richest
dividends this chapter includes many
matters that are connected with the
ability
of the commander to train his unit
so it's interesting what uh extreme
ownership we close out by saying this is
the most
challenging endeavor a human can
leadership is the most challenging
endeavor a human faces
and therefore the most rewarding i swear
we didn't steal that from him
even though he just said the exact same
thing even though he wrote a lot earlier
than us
you know what you know what it is though
like as when we talk
we talk with leaders all the time and
they say hey we're already doing a lot
of these things you're talking about
and uh and what the reason for that is
because
there's what works and there's what
doesn't work so no matter what you call
it you know
we gave a little framework around
extreme ownership the laws of combat but
uh
if you if you're in a leadership
position you're gonna uh
you're gonna figure out what actually
works and
that makes me think about this you talk
about psychology a lot
and not not in like psychological terms
and you know like clinical terms but in
like
trying to get people to do what you need
them to do to accomplish a mission with
and
that's exactly it human nature it took
me i don't know how many podcasts
must have been around i don't know but
at some point i said yeah this is a
podcast about human nature
really that's what it's about it's about
human nature and where human nature is
most revealed
is in war or in atrocities or
human suffering or human struggle that's
when
that's when human nature is revealed and
you know
we had this conversation and i don't
know when but
i remember telling you and stoner and
being like hey look when we go on
deployment
people are gonna go crazy and look i
didn't mean hey these people are gonna
but
you know when you talk about senior
leaders or you know
people are gonna start feeling pressure
and people do crazy things and i
saw that from my first deployment to
iraq i was thinking
wait a second this is just like people
are going crazy
so that's something that happens it's
it's just
human nature is revealed and if you're
if you're let's say you're nervous about
things let's say you're a nervous type
person
you're you're you're scared of something
what what's that going to do in combat
it's just going to get worse let's say
you're worried about things what's going
to happen in combat you're going to be
even more worried
let's say you have a tendency to focus
on things that don't really matter
you're going to do that even more in
combat it's like everything
you're just your human nature gets
exposed
to quote uh you it's combat is life
amplified and intensified it's true
and i think that's that's 100 true it's
100 true and it's like it's like that
friend that uh
that tells you like they go crazy when
they drink
and you're like no you're actually just
when you drink
you actually are crazy you're able to
keep it contained until you put the
alcohol in you
no you actually are crazy and it just
comes out
yes very similar uh here we go back to
the book
so you want a command how often have we
heard an officer say
i'd do anything to get a command have
you ever wondered
if he really meant it have you ever
wondered if you really
would make a good commander we have
often heard the expression a good
commander is born
not made this is interesting so he's
saying
hey we often hear a good commander is
born not made
you know how nowadays they say you know
actually anyone can be a leader
i shouldn't say it's such a a sarcastic
voice people say look anyone can be a
leader
you can learn what i talked about
leadership strategy and tactics is
it's both like you're gonna get some
natural qualities for sure some other
things you're gonna have to work in
so he says we often heard the expression
a good commander is born not made
and he says this is not entirely true
by exercising certain principles the
vast majority of officers can become
good commanders there you go he agrees
with me
let us see if considering the following
20 questions
will provide us with some guidelines if
the answers to these questions are yes
the potential commander's statement is
sincere
and he should fight to get it and should
be given
a command he will never have an
assignment that will give him greater
satisfaction or one that will enable him
to contribute more to the army and to
our country
so here's the 20 questions
is the officer seeking command duty
willing
to devote all hours of day and night
seven days a week to his command
is his wife willing to take an active
role
in helping to make a happy army
community
in their unit area is his family
willing to be secondary if necessary to
the company battalion group regiment
combat command brigade or division
i'm so glad he wrote that because i
still have people
that will call me out because i'll say
hey when i was in the teams the teams
came first
the teams were more important than my
family and
i'm sorry but you have to take care of
your guys
you have to
you mean when you would say things like
uh i'm gonna go home and
see this woman and these kids that live
at my house
yes and just for the record jocko was
jago's a loving husband and an awesome
dad uh but we knew that was a joke
it was pretty funny uh is he willing to
learn
teach stress and live with the
fundamentals necessary to make his unit
good
and believe his great talents for bigger
things are not to be wasted
does he like to be with young people can
he live with their energy points of view
and problems they create
is he willing to take the hard knocks
that come from carrying the
responsibilities
for the failures of his subordinates do
we get to pass these things on
echo charles i don't think so no we
don't
it sounds a little like extreme
ownership it certainly does can he
juggle at the same time all the balls of
training
maintenance test administration
inspections property communications
messes supplies athletics marksmanship
discipline
and public relations without dropping
any of them
prioritize and execute is he able to do
many
things concurrently rather than being a
consecutive doer can he manage a complex
job
can he receive and carry out orders can
he follow orders as well as give them
so number eight there is he able to do
many things concurrently rather than
being
a consecutive doer opposite of
prioritize and execute it's like i'm
gonna
i need to be able to do multiple things
at once here's what's interesting
i highlighted that and i started i was
thinking about it as i read through the
rest
of the book he starts to go into a
a delineation and a bifurcation between
between the title the book leader and
commander
and what he starts talking about is when
you're a leader
squad leader platoon leader at company
it changes to commander
and now what you have to do is realize
that you've gotta
you've gotta be able to task people to
do things right you gotta be able to
delegate
and so as a as a leader it's like
prioritize next you as a commander yes
you're going to prioritize and execute
but you're going to prioritize delegate
and then have other people doing
multiple things at the same time i mean
when we would go on an operation for
example
did we say okay right now we're only
going to set security
we're not going to do sensitive site
exploitation we're not going to do a
search right now we're only going to set
security no
we set security then we start
interrogating prisoners we start
searching
we start organizing our there's multiple
things that you're doing at the same
time
so that's different than hey
we've got we've got we're getting
attacked with multiple problems right
now
we need to focus on the biggest problem
and it also starts to
lean into talking about delegation and
how
and you know i've always said even when
i explain prioritize and execute
i say these words once you've got that
prob that first problem solved
or you've got it going in the right
direction then you can move on to the
next problem so if i
look if we're getting a contact from the
south and i go late take a platoon go
go start knocking those guys out i don't
even worry about you anymore
i'm good like i might check in with you
five minutes later to make sure you're
good but meanwhile
what am i doing i'm saying seth all
right continue the assault on this
building right it's not like i'm saying
everyone seth everyone online no if you
can handle it you handle it
another way i used to explain this is
let's say you're building a building
and you've got to get one of the rooms
electrical done because they're going to
put drywall in that room today
and you've got 10 electricians
on site and the room is small does that
mean you take
all 10 of your electricians and you pack
them into that room and put them all to
work no
because it's they're you don't need that
many you need four guys in there
that's the fastest and most efficient
you can get it done so you take those
four guys you put them in that room you
take the other six guys and they can
start doing something else
you don't just say that's the number one
priority everyone just sit in there and
do nothing
four guys do it and everyone else watch
them no you you handle the problem you
get it moving in the right direction
then you move on to the next then you
can take the remaining resources
and apply them to the next thing that
makes me think about target fixation
which is what we talk about with extreme
motor
with with uh privatization execute which
it's really easy like this is the
priority to get so focused on that
but i mean the example you just gave
like leave take your platoon and
take you hit that target of the south
and then seth you continued the assault
like
you wouldn't even say seth continue this
all because he's gonna he's gonna do it
and
and you talk about how your greatest
goal is to go on operations and not say
anything
um and i used to think that like that
was like
i wanted to be the leader like the you
know john wayne sands of iwo jima
with my helmet on sideways and my gun
and high port is my finger
his point you know like the plastic army
man with the finger pointing and his
the leader of this his uh his gun at
high poor point of this guy
and i so many times ramadi in the middle
of a big gunfight where you're like i'm
not saying anything at all my my
team's doing what they need to do the
fire team leaders are running the guys
the
squad leaders running their guys the
leading petty officers doing his thing
the
chief's doing his thing i can think two
steps ahead
um so i mean that's you have to be able
to do that that's decentralized command
when you get a team that's running that
then
you can you can handle 12 or 15 problems
at the same time because each of the
teams is doing their thing
i was talking to a client today and
he was talking to me about how he
sometimes has meetings
uh he'll have eight blocked meetings
in a day or ten
that he has to go to and he gets done
he's like yeah i know i got this meeting
this meeting and i had him pull up his
calendar
and he's talking me through each one of
these meetings
and i said um what's wrong with you
like what is wrong with you that every
like each one of your teams needs to
talk to you
every single day that's crazy to me
that's crazy to me
that's not decentralized command that is
centralized command
so you aren't giving the people the
right direction
they're not hearing what you're saying
they don't have the guidelines
you haven't given them the trust you've
been an easy but there's a
there's a bunch of reasons why it could
be happening but it shouldn't be
happening you shouldn't have to attend
those meetings all day long every day
because that's not decentralized command
it's not efficient
what happens if you aren't in those
meetings well the guys won't know what
to do
okay well there's your problem give them
the guidance and let them run
and if you're down in the weeds trying
to solve those problems which is what
you're doing
in the meetings then you can't who's
actually taking a step back i mean
that's you know when you wrote in that
the decentralized command chapter in
extreme ownership that
i mean we that have been a horrible blue
on blue situation that happened if you
were down in the weeds trying to tell
you know stoner uh seth stone how to run
his platoon you know
um that's just the way it is so i think
that's your job as the leader should be
to take a step back
and think strategically the the next
step the next step after that
and you can if you're down on the weeds
to make it making things and but you can
also see
where people need help and you could
step in temporarily when you take a step
back and you've got teams actually
handling those problems which you did
all the time as a ground force commander
when you're like
come over you walk in the house after we
call target security walking that's
what's going on
check in with me i'd give you a quick
update on what's going on you you kind
of
then you'd move to kind of where you
were needed you know where people might
need more resources or
hey we need some more guys outside you
know can we can you guys spare a fire
team
or hey we need more guys in the house
let's bring a fire team in yeah or
whatever it may be
yep yep got to do that um continuing
down this list
can he receive and carry out orders can
he follow orders as well as give them
hmm can he stand tough competition from
like units
and still retain a spirit of cooperation
and teamwork with him
god enemies outside the wire
is he physically and emotionally fit to
carry the load
that's what you and i just talked about
i talked about the mental side you
talked about the physical side
they're both freaking grueling does he
have the courage
to make and stand by tough decisions
are he and his family willing to live in
a goldfish bowl
where their actions are closely observed
by both subordinate and superior
is he still enthusiastic and cheerful
when confronted with seemingly
impossible tasks to perform
with inadequate means is he willing to
leave
a warm office to check and supervise
training maintenance
and many other activities of his unit is
he willing to take responsibility
himself
and correct the situation rather than
blame it on the staff
of a higher headquarters or on a
subordinate when things go wrong in his
unit
man we owe this guy some money
that's pretty phenomenal you know what
it's so humbling to hear that too and it
also doesn't
he's capturing the burden of leadership
so well you know
by obviously someone who's been and
lived it you know
at a multitude of levels and i think so
often we talk to like frontline troopers
or frontline you know leaders are like
if i was in the senior rigs but
everything would be great
and they don't fully understand the
burden of leadership and that's
that's a tough thing not not everybody
can do that and there are a lot of
people that don't want that
and i think once they get there they
realize like maybe that ain't for me
next is he willing to do the best with
what he has even though
what he has seems inadequate is he
confident he can produce
a superior unit with the usual run of
manpower
can he inspire personnel to produce
outstanding accomplishments
is he willing to take a chance on being
relieved
for attaining only mediocre results
does he really want command rather than
just to get command on his record
and i just realized he's got like a lot
of these 20 questions
there's like three or four questions in
each one he snuck some in on us
but what a what a great what a great
outline
just to just to check yourself
and see where you're at see how in the
game you are
next what does the soldier expect from
his commander
having dealt with the prerequisites of
command
so that's what we just did i offer these
thoughts
on what soldiers look for in their
commanders regardless of branch of
service
honest just and fair treatment men
admire a strict officer
if he is also just an officer who tries
to be a good fellow
loses his grip early an officer cannot
be expected to know
everything he cannot bluff his men and
retain their respect
when he does not know he should say so
and
then find and announce the answer like
we're i'm laughing as i'm reading this
you're laughing as i'm reading this this
is like straight out of leadership
strategy and tactics
um just it's it's crazy to sit here and
read this
you ask that question all the time like
who's got it all figured out
who has all the answers that nobody so
why would you even try to pretend like
you do
people you know and then we we get that
question from leaders like well
they'll lose respect for me you know if
i act like i i've got to pretend like i
know it all like
no everyone knows you don't know it all
so so they
they know you don't know and if you're
pretending they're losing respect for
you if you can actually admit you don't
know
uh and take ownership then uh offer a
mistake or whatever it happened that
obviously their respect is going up
i'll tell you another tricky situation
that that this offers some
insight into and it's not it doesn't
offer a definite answer but i've seen
leaders backed into a corner where you
know
leif screws something up and
whatever the mitigating circumstances
were you know i say you know what though
i got to punish him you know leif uh
life didn't finish the project on time
i'm writing him up
i told him i was gonna write him up i'm
gonna write him up and let you know you
come to me and say hey boss i get it
it's my fault here's some mistakes that
i made and i go yep
doesn't matter i'm writing you up and i
feel like i'm going to lose respect of
people if i don't
like drop the hammer on you and the fact
that matter is
you don't if you're re if you're a
reasonable human being
and you unders you you listen to the
mitigating
circumstance of a situation and say
you know what i really hope that this
doesn't happen again leif
there's no possible way if this happens
again i'm gonna let you off the hook
but you came to me with a plan on how
you're gonna fix these things
don't ever allow it to happen again your
respect for me doesn't go down
people don't think oh jocko's weak they
think
we got a boss that's going to take care
of our people now look if you have
somebody that's just out
you know does something totally off the
wall of course punishment must be dealt
out
but it's not weak to be reasonable
i guess that sums it up
speaking of punishment a commander
should administer punishment in an
impersonal way
and to a degree that fits the
circumstances and the offense
when a man pays his debt the commander
should fit forget the incident
you got to keep that thing in mind
though like you might have a repeat
offender you know you
i get it bro i get you general clark but
that one
you know you know what i i think what
he's saying there what what i interpret
that as is is
what you talk about in the first chapter
of extreme ownership this horrible blue
on blue situation
that was tragic that was terrible um and
the you know our commanding officers
coming to
you know find out what happened and we
think okay man they're probably gonna
fire someone for this
and there's a lot at stake and then you
talk about by taking ownership
by implementing a plan to make sure that
never happened again the boss
actually his trust increased in you
rather than decrease so
i mean i think when people take
ownership and they implement a solution
to make sure that
you see hey they're fixing that problem
you are gaining trust
even if something bad happens so it's
not that you're it's not that you're
forgetting about it but you're certainly
like
you're not holding it against you yeah
and i think that's the key thing isn't
yeah it's not
the literal term forget but you know i'm
not gonna look at you and go well you
know
i don't know leif last time you didn't
quite do what i needed you to do
no it's like hey you i you you made your
mistake
we figured out what the punishment was
gonna be you did your time for your
crime
we're gonna move on and i'm not gonna
hold it over your head that being said
you know i'm paying attention making
sure you're not a repeat offender
courage every man experiences fear in a
crisis the commander cannot show it
he must fortify himself by learning to
control his emotions
this is crazy to read consideration
do them so this is again this is all
under the topic what does the soldier
expect from his commander
consideration do them as mature
professional soldiers
regardless of age or grade soldiers
should be treated as mature individuals
they are men engaged in honorable
profession
and deserve to be treated as such
military courtesies start between
officers observation of these courtesies
between seniors and subordinates is not
belittling to either
they are evidences of the alertness
pride and good manners of your men
the commander's rank should be used to
serve his subordinates it is
not a reward and is not a license to
and exercise idiosyncrasies
rank has one object to enable the
officer to fulfill his responsibilities
subordinates expect the commander to
play his part according to his position
they do not begrudge him his rank
if he uses them if he uses it in the
interest of his subordinates and
superiors
so if you're using your rank in the
interest of your troops
we're good if you're using it for
yourself
we got an issue we got a problem you
know that part about
uh the professional these are
professionals treat them like
professionals
it reminds me of of our experience in
ramadi working alongside u.s
soldiers and marines and something you
always said about these guys are true
professionals they're
they're awesome professional warriors
that we were privileged and honored to
work alongside
and it was interesting how there are
some special operators that did not
treat them that way because they felt
like oh they were special and they went
through
some you know specialized training and
they were part of a specialized unit and
they had better gear
whatever and uh and and how
like they created all this bad blood
just by not treating people
professionally
and it was you know i just remember you
know meeting some of those young marines
and soldiers when we first
arrived there and they just you know
they they were looking at us like oh man
the seagulls are here and they look at
our
short barreled little rifles and our
cool gear and we had better night vision
all this
all this this stuff and i'm i'm looking
back at these these young privates
thinking man these guys have fired more
rounds to their weapons and
all of us put together in the entire
task unit are ever going to fire in our
entire careers in in the seal teams
i mean that's how much combat they were
seeing and it was just what an honor
and privilege to be i mean they were
they were absolute professionals and uh
that served us well by treating them
accordingly yeah
it's like one of those little golden
rules
why is this so hard treat people with
respect treat people with respect
that's it treat people with respect
personal interest taken in them as
individuals again what does a soldier
expect from his commander personal
interest taken in them
as individuals a good officer will know
the names background
and individual characteristics of his
men he must have a genuine personal
interest in them or they will not
have it in him each individual has
problems
there is no easy way of getting a grip
on men than by helping them solve their
personal problems
that give them great concern an officer
should not however be too familiar with
his men
good soldiers do not expect it and
usually resent it
it is not necessary to call soldiers by
their first names even if the officer
sleeps in the same foxhole with them
close but not too close as we like to
say the the dichotomy of leadership
yeah you know the the the expression and
i i didn't ever hear anyone say this
and i started saying it a little while
ago i don't know if maybe maybe it's not
gonna i don't know
i'm not trying to take credit for
something um
but you know you know the term that we'd
say in the teams which was take care of
your gear and your gear will take care
of you
which is means hey when you get done
with a dive
you take your dive rig and you do the
proper maintenance on it when you get
done with the
parachute jump you take your parachute
you do proper maintenance on it when you
get done with a fire
fight or operation you take your weapon
and you do the proper maintenance
you take care of your gear and your gear
will be there to take care of you same
thing with people you take care of your
people
and your people will take care of you
that's true as you're saying that though
i'm talking about some of those text
messages that
uh that you've sent echo charles yes sir
those things are going to become public
i think
yeah yeah might tell a different story
in a in a little way but
yeah man why is it so hard for people to
respect people
just no respect whatsoever my text
messages
to echo charles they do have
a high level of disrespect and this also
brings
to the fact that i believe i believe i'm
not 100 sure i believe
that i have a certain guard passing
technique
yes that is called the disrespect
literally
that i actually named because of you
because i would use this guard pass and
it's so disrespectful that you would um
you would feel disrespected did you
think of that name
no you did i remember very uh
vividly expand i like this
you don't have to it's just very
disrespectful that's it yeah
i think that's a good question you know
is it that hard to
to be respectful and apparently it is
sometimes
so yeah man
there's a fine line between jess and
disrespect and maybe uh
maybe a little more of a gray area yeah
yeah and it gets blurry sometimes
find some good screenshots and uh and
let's post some
some jocko echo texts i think that'll be
fun
okay uh back to the book there is
nothing
wrong today with the following
instructions
written by baron von steuben
at valley forge and published in the
continent
published by the continental congress
instructions for the captain
a captain cannot be too careful of the
company
a captain cannot be too careful
of the company the state has committed
to his charge
he must pay the greatest attention to
the health of his men
their discipline arms accoutrements
ammunition clothes and necessaries
his first object should be to gain
the love of his men by treating them
with every possible kindness and
humanity
inquiring into their complaints and when
well founded
seeing them redressed he should know
every man of his company by name and
character
he should often visit those who are sick
speak
tenderly to them see that the public
provision
whether of medicine or diet is duly
administered and
procure them besides such comforts and
conveniences
as are in his power the attachment that
arises from this kind of attention to
the sick and wounded
is almost inconceivable it will
moreover by the means of preserving the
lives of many
valuable men
so there you go what uh what a
what a incredible thing to be able to
read
instructions for a cap for a captain
from valley forge
that's powerful man it's humbling
as well too i think about all of my
shortcomings and
how much i could have used that guidance
directly you know prior to
being chartered a platoon commander or
you know even now like just reviewing
that and thinking about it and
it it captures i think like i said the
burden of leadership in a massive way
and all that's required of you which is
a lot
everything 100 all the time
and if you take care of your men your
men are going to take care of you and if
you have
this if you have this inconceivable
attachment what that does is
[Music]
is preserves lives so when you are a
tight unit
you know i've i've often said that you
know this the thing that makes a seal
platoon
strong is just the bonds that you have
like that's that's the difference that's
what that's what's gonna
that's gonna make the difference in any
military you know not just the seal i
mean i can talk about the seal platoons
because i've been in them
but any military unit what is it that
makes a really strong unit
it's how tight they are and what makes
people tight
you take care of them that's it
it goes on instructions for the
lieutenant
he should endeavor to gain the love of
his men
by his attention to everything which may
contribute to their health and
health and convenience he should often
visit them at different hours inspect
their manner of living
see that their provisions are good and
well cooked and as far as possible
obliged them to take their meals at
regulated hours
he should pay attention to their
complaints and when well-founded
endeavor to get them redressed
but discourage them from complaining on
every frivolous occasion
so for the captain and for the
lieutenant what are you trying to do
you're trying to build relationships
with your team you're trying to take
care of your people
and by the way those are the
instructions not one that's it
next i was just gonna say i think that's
that's the most profound thing to me you
know
as you think hey if hackworth is saying
everyone every officer should be
required to read this
you would think it's going to be talking
about tactics
how to set up you know your base of fire
and your assault elements or
you know how to position your troops and
and it's not that at all
it's it's all about building
relationships with your team you know
what's required of you to actually be a
leader um
it's uh how you you know how you manage
and lead
and that's that's pretty phenomenal and
we you say that all the time
something that we talk about often which
is the hardest part
of of combat leadership is is always the
the human aspect not the
not the tactics that's that's the easy
part yeah that that's
you know when i wrote the forward for
about face
you know and he turned you know he
turned against
he said hey we can't win this war if we
keep fighting like this
and and you know they they asked him
um they asked howard tucker in that
interview that famous interview
you know um he gets asked could you
could you could you become are you too
emotional about the war in vietnam
and hackword says one couldn't have
spent the number of years i spent in
vietnam without becoming emotionally
involved
one couldn't see the number of young
studs die or terribly wounded
without becoming emotionally involved
i have just seen the american nation
spend so much of its wonderful great
young men in this country
i have seen our national wealth being
drained away i see the nation being
split asunder
and almost being uh being split apart
and almost being split asunder because
of this war and i'm wondering to what
end it will lead to
end quote
you know like that's a guy that loved
his troops
i can only imagine that burden you know
with 58
000 dead in the vietnam war 58 000 u.s
troops killed and uh because even at the
tiny fraction of that number you know
that we've experienced in afghanistan
and iraq
coming back from iraq when we came back
from ramadi i think one of the hardest
things for me just
after having lost mark with ryan was
blind
mikey you know we lost mikey and del
platoon
and a good friend of mine
who's hopefully going to be on this
podcast with you sometime elliott
uh who was severely wounded and he was
in brook army medical center in san
antonio which is the primary burn care
facility for all of
all of the u.s military and so i went
and spent a bunch of time with him
there and from december for you know
really through much of like 2007 back
there regularly
and and trying to try to you know just
help him support him and his family
wherever we could
and just witnessing the
those burn victims in there you know
when ieds that were causing you know
the enemy's most valuable weapon and
you're walking into those
those icu rooms and you're seeing young
soldiers and marines with no lips no no
noses no ears
just face you know faces burned off it
was uh one of the most horrific things
i've i've ever had to experience and
when i would hear people on the news
talking about the war and
pontificating about the blood and
treasure that we spent and they had
no inkling of of just how
deep and personal that was you know
um and again that's just a fraction in
the iraq war of what hackworth
experienced
in vietnam i can only imagine you know
for him and for every other vietnam
veteran out there
um what that was like but there's
there's no way to not make that personal
yeah and you can see the root of that
is you know this it's the same route
like you said earlier these things that
you uncover over time you know if you
take care
if you if you love your troops that's
gonna be
that's that's what it's about and
hackworth knew that you know that i know
that general clark knew that
that's the way it is
it goes on here loyalty
loyalty to superiors and subordinates
is a basic requirement
criticism of a commander's superiors in
front of subordinates lays him open to
the same treatment
he should stand up for his men as he
expects them
to stand up for him
you can you can you can almost see
hackworth's life unfold
right like you can see that that
statement
in everything that he did
an officer's presence when the
conditions are unpleasant and when the
going is tough
sharing the situation of the men means a
great deal to them
pick up the brass the commander should
act as a buffer between superiors
and subordinates he should protect his
men
from harassment that comes from above
but still get the job done
yeah i know sometimes i would pull back
the curtain for a few minutes
and like show you what was happening
above me in the chain of command
on all different fronts and look
everyone up above me in the chain of man
doing their job but it's
it's it's pressure and it's
it's kind of maddening and and sometimes
i would be asking you for something
and you'd get pissed off about it you
know what the hell you need this for and
i'd say
come here for a minute let me let you
take a look behind this curtain for 15
seconds
you look back there see that sausage
getting made and say okay i'm good i'll
get you what you need i'm out thank you
you did it you always did a great job of
screening uh us from that
and uh but i think that was very
valuable for me because it gave me a new
perspective i
you know like oh they're asking us for
this you know i'm getting mad about it
and then i realized like how much you're
actually screening out you know
of that harassment like hey i'm keeping
these guys off your back so that you
guys can go do what you need to do
next that their needs be anticipated and
met
a good soldier has needs both spiritual
and physical and the commander should do
everything possible to anticipate and
meet those needs
at the same time he should provide all
the comforts and privileges practicable
this is not meant to imply that he
should coddle his men
or treat them as babies like how
beautiful is this dichotomy
just when you think oh maybe he's a
little off track here maybe i'm a little
bit known
this does not mean to imply that he
should coddle his men or treat them like
babies
such things as a hot meal when it is not
expected
unit parties liberal past privileges and
good recreational facilities are more
more to the point
next thing that the soldier expects from
his commander to be kept
informed and told the reason why
the commander should keep his men
informed at all time tell them the
reasons behind decisions affecting them
many jobs seem purposeless unless the
facts behind them
are known
he should continually take action to
offset rumors and speculation by giving
his men
all the information he can yeah we owe
this guy money
dude we owe this guy money
you know what though you're probably uh
i mean obviously there's a direct
influence right through
david hackworth you know in a bow face
from
general clark i think you could go back
to the greek hoplites or the you know
the roman legions and probably find some
centurion who's writing the same stuff i
mean they're learning the same stuff
it's some some different aspect a
different terminology a little bit
different
you know a vastly different error uh
millennia apart but it's
it's human nature as we just said hasn't
changed
and uh and i bet there would be
something very similar
and just to make sure everyone realizes
we're not
just talking about war we are talking
about leadership we're talking about
leadership in business
you need to tell your people what's
going on and they need to understand why
they're doing what they're doing
i'm talking about your family they need
to understand what's going on
and they need to understand why they're
doing what they're doing
any any situation where you're
interacting with other human beings
these rules apply and they apply to the
point
why do we know that they work because
they've been tested we tested them but
these guys test them in even
crazier conditions harder conditions
three freaking wars
that's that's one of the most common
things we're getting at echelon front
these days is
questions about managing the family
schedule and
how do i work from home with you know
with so many people still working from
home
you know it's uh those are those are
like a good bulk of the questions
about that and that directly applicable
well the other thing that's been
interesting is
with covet hit you know most of the
companies that we work with are good
companies that want to be awesome
we do get some companies that that come
to us sometimes against their will
brought to us by the board or whatever
that we
are going to fix them help fix them most
of the companies we work with are good
companies that want to do better
when covid hit the so these companies
aren't companies that are struggling
these are companies that just want to do
you know better and so they would
implement the the principles that we
talk about implement cover move
implement simple
prioritize next year decentralize
command default aggressive you know
extreme ownership so they implement
these things and and yes they're
absolutely start doing better
and we watch them and we get feedback
from them and their profits go and they
become more efficient and more effective
and they start taking market share
everything goes awesome
and it's cool and everyone goes hey yeah
that's great and we're super excited
about it when covet hit and all of a
sudden there was companies that were
in dire situations and were able to
utilize the principles
to survive yes but also
start to actually go on the attack and
thrive
that was pretty epic because it
basically was like
uh have you ever did you ever pull a
reserve parachute
never had yeah i only did it one time
and all the other times i'd be like yeah
cool yeah i'm glad i got a reserve on
the time that i pulled out i was like
this thing's freaking awesome bro
thank you for packing this thing
correctly case of beer to the rigor
you know because you because normally
it's just like yeah yeah
it's work you know it's on there it's
all good and that's kind of what
companies you okay we're doing really
good hey our profits are up all these
all these positive things but also when
they're faced with real
hardships and challenges they're like
what should we do here prioritize next
year
oh yeah okay or die yeah they no longer
exist
exactly hey what you know we've got this
going we got all these people working at
home
what should we do this is decentralized
command yeah we've been doing that well
yeah now you need to do it harder you
need to make sure everyone understands
what the mission is what the goal is
what the end state is
you need to communicate with them they
need to understand why they're doing
what they're doing
can you make that happen yes we can okay
execute
you know that makes me think there was a
there was an educator remember on ef
online
uh a few weeks ago as as they were about
to go back to school you know in her
state or
her her district she was an educator she
was talking about how crazy it was and
how much
uncertainty it was and uh and you said
we didn't learn this stuff in a boy
scout troop you know how this
we learned this on the battlefield it
was crazy it was chaotic
there was a lot at stake there was a lot
of uncertainty about what was gonna
happen like
what you need to do is prioritize and
execute that's where this came from and
i think
i know it's getting crazy in that sixth
grade classroom
and i'm telling you this is gonna work
and it did and she came back and gave us
a great uh sit rep about how
it was she was implementing that and
moving forward and doing great
legit next thing that the
soldier requires is a well thought out
program of training work and recreation
the commander should keep a balance
between training and recreation too much
of either becomes a drag on the men
logical progression of training helps
the helps keep the men from becoming
confused
um yeah this is exactly what we wrote
about dichotomy leadership
train hard but train smart you can smoke
people you can crush them to the point
where they're not getting any benefit
anymore
next demands commensurate with
capabilities
neither too great nor too small a
commander should not
overload his men with unnecessary work
on the other hand
letting men become bored because they
are not working enough is just as bad
neither men as individuals nor unit
should be expected to accomplish
impossible attacks what is that what do
you say you got to balance that
dichotomy
it sounds like general clark had the
same experience with his soldiers that
we always said like a board team guys
like the most dangerous thing in the
universe
because they're going to figure
something out to go cause trouble or
because create me because rock fights
that was when i was a young team guy if
there wasn't
if we weren't being told to do something
like sitting around waiting for
something there was a rock fight
happening
you know also someone just hits you in
the leg with a rock from
20 yards and it's a rock fight or uh or
actually actually it wasn't rock fights
there was a couple of those but mostly
you're not talking about like tossing a
pebble you're talking about [ __ ] no
what it was it wasn't rock fights that's
when i was a kid when i was a kid there
was rock
fights and i don't know what you're even
thinking when you're having rock fights
but we had we had bb gun wars yeah we
had bb gun
shoot your buddy in the leg with your we
had a bb gun wars if you got shot red
rider bb gun if you got shot you had to
take off one layer of clothing
by the way zero eye pro i think it was
just the dumbest thing
what's that i got hit in the face once
i came home one time my eyes swollen so
shut and my dad was like
son what happened to you i got hit with
a spear
we were having spear wars there you go
sharpen sticks throwing them into each
other it hit me
i mean it messed my eye by like three
millimeters
my dad was like you're an idiot don't
ever do that again
anyway rock fights oh yeah not rock
fights hucking rocks at objects it'd be
like hey who can hit that so i guess
it's similar to the pebble but it'd be
like hey who can hit that
lamp over there you know that street
light or something we'll start sitting
there hucking rocks at it
speaking of board team guys and rock
fights so my first deployment before we
worked together in tuscany and bruiser
in 2004 so after your first appointment
to iraq one of our
super solid team guys you know in our
platoon
was throwing rocks through the window
of uh and got in all kinds of trouble
because he damaged this
smash and shattered a window of of this
like former saddam palace
and they literally like like pulled an
award for him i made it crazy
this this palace had uh a j damn drop to
the middle of it it was completely like
for some reason they got all upset that
he like shattered the windows
what's this jay down uh a giant bomb
dropped from the sky it's a it's a gps
guided bomb
[Music]
you know what there weren't too many
times a task in a bruiser where we had
board team guys because you always had
us busy doing stuff
but uh the one time that we did let it
go
um the andrew paul
got volunteered to demonstrate the new
tasers that we got
yeah i remember that and chris kyle
tased him and uh
everyone sat around filming it and
laughing andrew said that was the worst
experience of his entire life
the cool thing there was a safety
officer there that someone
someone made like we put out the jiu
jitsu mats because this was remember
we're new jiu jitsu in the morning in
the high bay there
and i forget you know i heard someone
came like hey jocko they're about to
taste andrew paul i'm like i'm doing
work i'm like all right i better go tell
you you're like you're earmuffs did you
go check it out
i don't even remember it might have been
one of those things where i was like all
right let the boys do what the boys are
gonna do
maybe i just saw the video yeah i think
you probably saw that i saw the video
but i saw that there was a mat they took
our green they were actually my mats
they took them
put them down underneath so he fell face
down on the freaking mat
thankfully yeah that uh board team guy's
bad
didn't he say he was gonna fight through
it
i think so he did not fight through it
andrew tall's a tough tough dude but
that taser took him down
all right back to the book guidelines to
orders
give orders this is ridiculous give
orders in a manner which indicates you
expect compliance
do not issue orders you cannot enforce
give clear
complete correct orders and follow them
up i mean the reason i said this
ridiculous is because it's just crazy
that
what the actual verbage that we use when
we brief is
you know give simple clear concise
guidance and here they're saying clear
complete correct
only by long and careful training can
the commander achieve
perfection in giving orders ambiguity
vagueness and incompleteness of orders
are to blame for the mo
for most disobedience and failure to
comply
which is when i say
if your team isn't doing what you what
you want them to do the very first
person you should check is yourself and
here it is
and yeah that's so hard for any of us to
do right you get
frustrated with the person for not doing
what you wanted them to do and
instead of actually looking at yourself
and saying hey okay obviously
i wasn't clear i could have done a
better job
the words of an order indicate what is
to be done
the manner in which it delivers
generates the spirit in which it will be
carried out
oral orders should be repeated back
failure to do so will most assuredly
result in a grave
misunderstanding only
by long and careful training can men
learn to receive
obey and pass on orders to others
lack of orders does not relieve a
commander from acting
you must strive to come to maintain a
complete picture
of the situation so you can take
suitable action in the absence of orders
it is a wise officer who refrains from
criticism
until he can make logical constructive
suggestions an officer
should be as good as his word he should
not make promises he cannot keep
or make decisions he cannot support
just perfect guidance on how you how you
tell people what it is you want them to
how you give orders
the combat commander positive leadership
battle appears to add peculiar problems
to command
but when further analyzed the problems
are merely magnifications of those
present in training
the great difference between combat and
training is the presence of danger and
confusion in combat
these two obstacles can be overcome only
by positive leadership
and by developing a positive and
automatic reaction
in the individual soldier
that's cool it's cool that it says this
like we absolutely
added confusion massive amounts of
confusion into our training to simulate
the we couldn't you know you can't shoot
people obviously during training you
can't add that element of danger but you
certainly can add some freaking
confusion
the yeah the term i think i always use
was chaos and mayhem
you know like for sure like activate
chaos and mayhem and your your
trade instructors were awesome in doing
that they were very awesome at doing
that
these positive traits of the commander
and of the soldier are acquired during
training training in peace training in
wartime before combat training during
battle
and by mental factors not easily
described
desire to overcome the enemy devotion to
country
and organization and personal devotion
to the commander
when a disciplined unit is spurred by
the mental drives mentioned
it fights not only well but brilliantly
those are some
awesome things to strive for the with
the
the willingness to overcome the enemy
devotion to country and organization and
personal devotion to the commander
battle is fought for real money and for
keeps battles are won by teamwork
not by individuals acting alone
the only teamwork that can stand up
under the confusion and constant danger
feeling of fear and physical exhaustion
is the battle of instinctive
teamwork success in combat is due
largely to
endurance on the battlefield the day
after day strain of living in the
dirt of going without sleeping food of
the constant threat of death
will cause men cause the man who is
physically or mentally weak to quit
fatigue makes cowards men in good
physical condition
are the last to tire
i would i would definitely agree with
that for sure
you know what though man i i was just
thinking about like going through the
strain
and stress of like i i think i just
think about the support
of the team you were talking about the
bonds between teams and relationships
and uh just that that attitude you know
you talk about the respect of the
commander and and
you know obviously you know we always no
one ever wanted to let you down
to you bruiser clearly um but i think
understanding the mission and just
like looking at another guy you could be
under fire in a crazy situation
and you know i look at like tony tony
like look back at you or
you know even that situation i said
earlier where dave burke and a couple
other you know of our guys ran down to
grab the pallets of water like interact
with you or when you came down
you know for a delivery uh you know to
resupply us you know you're just
showing up for just a few minutes
checking us out seeing how things are
going like
and i think just the look and and you're
out like hey cool how things going down
here
it's no matter what the physical strain
is on you you know or what you're going
through at mental strain it's it's uh
i think that support of your teammates
around you and like the attitude
particularly the kind of attitude of
humor in
i think the midst of some really dire
situations i think was always
super helpful for us yeah
that the um attitude that people have
and i i would love to tell you it's
leaders but as you know full well
it's not just leaders it can be anyone
in the platoon
anyone on the team anyone in the
organization when things are going bad
and someone says dude we got this you
know or whatever
someone instead of saying oh you know
hey we gotta roll out again
you're gonna be kidding me someone goes
good let's bring it
you know like that little thing the best
exam power man
there it is and the best example i can
think of is
we wrote about in the planning chapter
of of extreme ownership which
you know me and everyone else is jacked
up we're about to launch on that hostage
rescue operation and
me and you're sitting in there and and
uh butters are you know
intel insane comes rolling in and goes
they got a high ds buried in the yard
and booker machine gun positions in the
house and you just looked at me
and put this big smile on your face like
i guess you guys are gonna get something
and i was like i guess we are i mean it
was that's and that attitude
instead of being like you know if you
looked at me like oh no yeah do you do
you think you know maybe we shouldn't go
on this you know it was like
no you just started you were like
smiling and laughing about it
now look obviously we planned and put
pretenses in place we weren't being
callous about it but it was
that attitude was contagious for
everybody uh you know our mark lee
rolling out on the
as the lead turret gunner like mark you
feel lucky tonight like everybody's a
winner
you know so pay attention to that
because it's real easy it's real easy
uh it's really easy to let that bad
attitude come out and you need to just
stifle that thing
you just need to stifle it and anybody
that wants to talk to me about being
transparent
and showing your feelings um i'll say
no no actually just be quiet just shut
up and what you need to do is
you go oh this is going to suck and i'll
look at leif and say this
you guys are going to get some watch
this let's go brit let's go bring it
the importance of endurance on the
battlefield is underlined by grant's
philosophy the idea that in
every battle there may come come a
moment when each side is fought out and
ready to quit
and the belief that in such a moment
victory will go to the side which is
able to make
one final effort
in the heat of a firefight the poor
commander will not be able to lead men
into danger
to make them attack or keep order when
he and his men are under hostile
artillery fire he won't be able to
execute his plans
instead his men will forget teamwork and
follow their own plans
in fighting for survival therefore you
must take every opportunity to make your
men confident in your ability to command
and of the skill and toughness of your
unit
unit morale the prospect of entering
battle
puts every soldier under severe nervous
strain
dangers real and imaginary are thick
around them
the commander can overcome much of this
strain
and strengthen the mental endurance of
his men by teaching them
in advance what to expect an event
for seen and prepared for will have
little
harmful effect
you were talking about uh grant's
philosophy
there and i was thinking about um
chamberlain at gettysburg we were just
at gettysburg for ef battlefield and
i mean they you know he in the the 20th
main charged
fixed bayonets and charged down the hill
and little round top that was
the absolute last ditch ever they didn't
have any ammo i mean it was
it was it was it was you know
millimeters uh
close to to losing that battle and that
would have changed the entire
tide of the battle you know if little
round top had been taken so i think
that's such a phenomenal example of to
me that's that
default aggressive mindset of like hey
okay
we're going to be default aggressive to
to continue this and that one last bush
is going to change the entire outcome
there's a famous boxing match with
muhammad ali and i want to say
i want to say
i can't remember which match it was but
it is a brutal
boxing match and at one point
both fight muhammad ali's all beat up
and whoever he was fighting i forget it
was
it was an incredible fight but
he gets back to his corner and he's
telling his
corner cut him off he's done cut my
gloves off i'm done
and basically these corners like you got
you know you got to keep going and they
look over and the other guy didn't
answer the bell
so like that's that's where it's at like
if you you can give up right there
that's something to think about you know
like can you just go a little bit more
can you just go a little bit more
back to the book in combat you really
see the critical importance of high
morale and esprit de corps
morale must be high enough to stand the
shock and boredom of combat
you know actually before i continue here
i want to say this that thing about
giving people a heads up about what
they're going to face
like that you know you're gonna like if
you
i've had fighters where
they're they got their first big of the
they're on the big stage maybe they're
in the ufc for the first time or
whatever
they get nervous and they don't know
what
that is no one ever told them hey man
you're going to feel you know you're
going to feel sick you're going to feel
butterflies
uh tito ortiz you know dean used to
corner tito a lot
and tito and they just they just had a a
uh
show about tito versus chuck and one of
the scenes you can see it's tito
he's right about to walk out and he's
throwing up just viciously throwing up
and but i remember dean telling me tito
would get so nervous before fights that
he would just
start throwing up but he understood what
it was
now imagine you you're just going in
your first fight
and all of a sudden you start you want
to throw up and
someone just be like hey just go ahead
and throw up just get it out you know
just oh just get it out of your system
it's the same thing in combat you got to
say hey listen you're you're nervous
it's okay if you're jittery if you're
if you feel sick if you whatever it's
okay
that's just your body you know focusing
its energy towards where it needs to be
focused to it's perfectly fine
but if you don't know that it can be a
problem
uh back to the book so morale must be
high enough to stand the shock and the
boredom of combat
every man must be strong must strongly
believe that what he is doing is right
he must have
supreme confidence that he can deal with
any situation that he is a better
fighter than the enemy
esprit de corps is unit morale every man
must feel that his unit is a superb
fighting unit
and that he like the rest will sacrifice
even life itself for the unit
the spirit is often the difference
between mediocre and superior armies
it was strong in the robin legions and
the french troops under napoleon
recognize though that the commander must
inspire beyond
group esprit only deep personal
convictions
springing from the identification with
the cause will drive a man forward
when his unit is destroyed or scattered
personal example the commander should
be a model soldier
he must master the technique of war
as it fits his assignment he must
improve and expand his technical
knowledge
the commander must strive to make it
possible for every soldier to say
truthfully
the old man knows the old man always
knows the right thing to do
in addition he must exhibit daily a fine
example of stamina
and courage besides his own example the
higher commander is also represented by
his staff officers
they too must reflect the superior
qualities of their commander
above all set
the proper example
leading by example there you go the
model
soldier soldiers morale show me a unit
that is well run
properly trained and ready for combat
and i'll show you a unit with high
morale
no commander will readily admit that his
unit's morale is anything other than the
next one
i wrote the leadership strategy and
tactics people always ask how do i
improve do hard things
you want to improve morale do hard
things
as we compare units however it is often
obvious that morale in some units is
more excellent than in others what is
morale
our manual on leadership defines morale
as the mental and emotional state of the
individual although it is a complex and
intangible quality
the manifestations of its absence in a
unit
can be detected readily in the form of
poor appearance
of the individuals of the individuals
and unit area
poor discipline and a low state of
training
that's something that i mean obviously
hackworth immediately
applied that you know to the the hard
from the hard luck to the hardcore
first italian and uh i was thinking
about that with tasking bruiser
something that we talk about often which
is
you know the the initially we were
working harder than everybody you know
that people
were working harder than we were
preparing for scenarios that we
the guys that have been to iraq
previously like what man why are we
training for this crazy
multi-casual scenario you know that we
we didn't experience anything like that
on the
on the battlefield or when the
instructors say hey you guys are good to
go and we said you know what we need to
do a few more runs
and there was grumbling around that
people were people were saying hey we're
working harder than you you know we're
coming in early we're staying late we're
not taking the night off and going out
drinking beers in town
we're actually planning and training and
preparing you know
and uh it's interesting to think about
how those complaints just faded away as
our performance
increased and i mean that was morale
that's that's morale increasing to say
hey
we're tasking a bruiser hey why why are
we working harder than
you know these other tasks because we're
tasking a bruiser that's why
because we strive to be better than
everybody and that's what we're going to
do
and uh that's yeah i mean that's that's
a
that's awesome 101.
more stuff i stole from hack hackworth
several adjuncts to morale chart three
good management we all like to be in a
unit where things run smoothly where
things are planned where men do not have
to hurry up and wait
adequate information men like to be kept
informed ahead of time of things that
affect them
or are apt to affect them it is far
better for the commander to keep his men
informed
than have the men seek to get such
information from rumors
high state of training if a unit is not
well trained its men
know it this fact shakes their
confidence especially if they anticipate
the possibility of using that training
in a critical situation chances for
advancement
progress is morale raising to all men
knowing that advancement is possible and
that excellent performance and
preparation lead to promotion
helps morale good physical and mental
condition
good physical condition goes hand in
hand with good mental condition
these two elements are basic to
achieving good morale
good administration men like to know
that their pay and accounts
and individual records are correct
confidence and equipment ours is the
best equipment
a best equipped army in the world
confidence and commanders men expect
their commanders to know their jobs to
share the hardships with them and to
take a personal
interest in their problems you will not
know whether a particular officer or
soldier has a problem until someone has
heard his case
a willing ear will gain much confidence
comfortable quarters i'm
paraphrasing some of these mess good
food
mail service medical attention post
exchange facilities leaves and passes
religious services and character
guidance
it is especially important that a army
be made up of mostly young soldiers be
provided with facilities for religious
services
in accordance with their preferences a
program of character guidance will help
to continue in the service the wholesome
influence of home and community life
awards and letters accommodation
standards soldiers like to be in a sharp
unit they appreciate achievement of high
standards in discipline dress
housekeeping police maintenance training
and athletics
the lift and morale that comes from
impressive and well-executed military
ceremonies is an important factor
that kind of reminds me of like uh group
pts
you know with the team and everyone like
hates group pt's like
grumbles like group group pts and then
you get together and you do some awesome
workout together and afterwards like
that's awesome that was great
you know um we just got some little help
from external sources
that it was we'll move on to this in a
second we've got a little some little
help from external sources
that it was ali frazier when that fight
happened when that fight i was talking
about
earlier happened and it was frasier
his frasier's corner was basically
saying you're done
and ali's was over telling his coroner
caught him off
i'm done and frazier's corner said
you can't you're done and that was it
ali
ali's corner you know was no you can't
caught up you're fighting again you're
fighting more
and he decided to stick you know that
was it he won
for an ex he he held on for an extra
three seconds
and got the victory after a 15-round war
it wasn't a
or a 14-round war going into the 15th
round
but i like that like when i know look i
know i'm not the most talented and
gifted
person in any way shape or form but i
know that i'm
i if someone's have if i'm having a hard
time i know someone else is too
and i know that i will answer the bell
and i know that's gonna
that's gonna be a problem it's gonna be
a problem for somebody
you know that that's i think for a lot
of us like it's kind of human nature to
focus on yourself you know and think oh
if you're having a struggle and it's
you know it's you something you talk
about whether it's you know disciplining
this freedom waking up you know
at the alarm early in the morning and
how it's like you're a human being it's
hard for you it's hard for anyone to do
that but it's
we kind of like to think oh it's harder
for me and
without the recognition of like man this
is it's hard for everybody and if i can
push a little bit harder
it's going to give me the advantage i
figured that out in
hell week for me i wasn't the fastest
runner i wasn't the fastest swimmer
but like by like day two of hell week
everyone is crushed i was like
dude i'm good to go like i all of a
sudden i can i can hang with guys that
were way faster runners than me
you know they they were hurt more and
and it's like even the score
so i think that's uh that gives you a
pretty huge advantage if you can keep
grinding
yeah the tough times you that with that
the normal face philosophy helps so much
because it jumped like and i'm obviously
thinking about like a jiu-jitsu
situation or whatever where you're
competing against someone directly
where if they're gassing or whatever
they're they're uh
in a state of extreme adversity we'll
say and they interpret because just like
how you're saying leave how you're like
hey we're so focused on ourself i'm
focused on how tired i am i don't know
how tired this guy is
all i have really is his external what
he's doing or looking like
but if the other guy's just like
cruising in his face like he's
really comfortable you're like man i
can't compete with this at all so now
you want to give up even more you can
never
like the the joke about normal face is
no joke man
it really isn't it really truly isn't
and you talk about
you talk about um you know like when how
many times have you seen me
like we're doing jiu jitsu or even not
you training with me but me training
with anybody me training with dean lisch
yeah you know training with somebody
that's better than me that's giving me a
run
have you ever seen like a look on my
face of just like despair
no so and i saw and i told this story
probably more than once before already
on here
but there was a time where you were
rolling with dean and you know
hey with all due respect he was he was
kicking your ass
yeah pretty bad too and i was like dang
absolutely seen jock over
and you guys were going hard that's the
thing and that's the part that really
like stuck with me i'm like man i would
be grassing right now like hardcore you
know you scrambled and you scramble
again you scramble again you scramble
again
and then you kind of rest through it but
you guys weren't even doing that i was
like man
and you're getting your ass kicked so
i'm like jocko's in a world of hurt
right now then he had you in mount
double snow angel and i'm like i would
be i was feeling literally like
physically claustrophobic because of how
tired i was like
empathetically getting from watching you
guys and like how your arms were or
whatever i was like
man i don't know how he he can even take
that or whatever and then you ended up
sort of getting out and the round
ended and i was looking at your face and
you're just like kind of like
that's what you do every day kind of
thing i was like i don't that's what i
knew was like okay this kid's a little
bit different than the normal person
you know you do that even when uh
probably the lowest point that i've seen
you
um when seth stone and i came to visit
you in the hospital after your next
surgery
and we went and bought you a big like
danny slam burger you know like double
cheeseburger
like we're gonna go let's go see jocko
he just had his surgery
and uh we roll up there and you were
just in and you were like normal
i knew you were hurting back because you
did like like just set it down over
there
but you were still like normal face and
i don't know what you look like before
we walked in there
but you definitely turned on the normal
face yeah when uh
you know and i knew you had to be in
massive pain you're just coming out of
neck surgery that you had all these
those nerve issues and um they had you
on a bunch of you know
drugs and stuff but you even still were
normal facials well it's freaking
getting neck surgery because of dean
lister that's what the deal is
but it's a real thing and and also i
mean look leif you've come to me with
many times with all kinds of uh
you know bad bad news you know whether
it's just
hey you know whether even it's just
something stupid like i'm thinking of
some dumb stuff like uh
you lost some gear right some let's say
some critical gear which you did
or your platoon did which means you did
like
you know you come to me and you go hey
hey boss
uh we lost this that the other thing and
i go
okay oh looks like we have to fill its
paperwork right like
it's a real thing and if i can't control
my emotions because you lost a piece of
gear your platoon lost a piece of gear
like how am i going to react in the
future by the way
when you're saying i lost a piece of
gear like we're talking about like i'm
coming and telling you i lost a
15 000 pair of like pvs 15
like night vision which can be used by
the enemy yeah which is a big deal or we
lost
a uh a kick 13 which is you know
uh a cryptologic device that uh you know
that we use for radios
it's a cryptological device
that when you lose means the entire
country of america has to update their
cryptological loads
which is uh a giant deal and so for
jocko to just give you
the normal face on that it's actually
the worst it's like your dad telling you
he's
he's uh he's not angry he's just
disappointed
i mean it's actually the worst because
if you were like dude are you kidding me
you know like i i would be looking it
was it would be desirable when john was
like
roger and just looks back at you like
doesn't mean we can't
maybe it's on the other side of like
your brain or something but doesn't it
give you like a big sense of comfort
like okay
at least this is manageable like it's a
big deal but at least it's manageable
because like if you're already kind of
freaking out for whatever reason
and you bring it to him who's like part
of the reason you're kinda
apprehensive about the whole thing to
say the least and
he doesn't freak out so it's like it
feels like
in your mind you're like okay maybe this
this whole chaotic situation that just
emerged
is kind of manageable more well
i i mean look to me there's there's
there's definitely like
it's it's more difficult to handle a
boss is like doesn't freak out about it
right when you're like
because you don't want to let that boss
down you you want to let that boss down
you're like hey man
it's like roger you know and it's it's a
um it's it's it's harder it's more
but i guess to your point echo it's
you're gonna i'm gonna actually fix that
problem i'm gonna make sure it doesn't
happen again
whether if you do if you flipped out
about it and you know yelled and
screamed at me then that's my punishment
whereas
the pun the punishment for me is knowing
like it's constructive
because i know like i gotta get this
fixed we can't let this happen again
this is a massive issue hey okay i know
we gotta send out a message and tell the
entire
u.s military you know department of
defense
send another jackass message yeah and so
you know what i'm going to start writing
the message right now
let me do it let's get it yeah you know
that's that's uh
that's probably not the best example i
could have picked because
as i'm thinking about it what you're
saying is accurate like it's
it's more tormenting for me just to be
like all right
cool roger you know as opposed to being
like i can't believe you did that
because now
you can be like god jack was such a jerk
and it's almost like you know we can
have a little spat
over it as opposed to me just late uh
just saddling you with unbearable guilt
for letting me down
but is that look the reality is it gets
the problem fixed
it gets the problem fixed i mean with
it's not unbearable guilt it's like okay
we can't let that happen again this is a
huge deal and we gotta get we gotta
we gotta i'm gonna make sure this
doesn't happen again which is gonna be
better for me gonna be better for you
gonna be better for our team
gotta be better for everybody rather
than like oh
okay i got yelled at you know and and
that's the end of it you know
yeah and even like when they flip out on
you or something you're like yeah i
messed up but like
he didn't have to flip out on me like
that you know so it kind of
like not justifies but it kind of
lessens
yeah it gives you it gives you a cause
right yeah
freaking just lost his mind with me on
that you know what i mean and you go
back to the platoon you go
dude chocolate just totally freaked out
he's freaking out about this
that guy turns a mountain into a
molehill every time yeah right all of a
sudden it's me against you yeah
and then turns into me against your
platoon so it's just all bad
one thing i will say about normal face
and i could say this because
anybody that knows me knows that i'm
probably the worst
one of them yeah the worst normal face
guy ever like it is a
real struggle for me uh to like
maintain normal face it's funny because
i
i mean you yes it is not a strength of
yours
but you are better now because man back
in the day
it was just like i would be looking at
you going oh this is my face is getting
ready
it's turning red just clenching your
teeth
i'd be like oh jack lame's getting spun
up this ought to be good
i'd be thinking like please please don't
say anything until the boss leaves or
whatever i'll
i'll handle it dude you don't have to
say anything
and uh yeah that would be good but what
i was going to say is this is a great
example of this one equals freedom right
and your kids well we know i mean i've
known them since they all are
super little and watch them growing up
and
you have helped them you know train them
in that like like help
they're you're practicing that and it's
something that you got to practice it's
something you have to
you can get better with reps even if
you're not naturally good at it like me
you can definitely get better
with reps and and so i i've improved
i've got a long way to go still
but i think you got to be thinking about
it all the time and that's you know
we've talked about on
the podcast years ago when i was here
like you're
the chaos at home i got young kids at
home that's a great example to like
accept that as like a
okay i'm not gonna spin up this is a
good chance to practice normal face
right now
when i'm upset i'm frustrated we're not
getting out the door
for the road trip or whatever it is that
we all get i get spun up about all the
time and it's a
if you accept that as like a training
opportunity
then you're when you actually need to
use normal face
you will actually be much better at
doing it bro you
you mentioned like training and the kids
and stuff the whole reason it's called
normal face is because it's an actual
game
that this guy plays played whatever with
the kids
with the it's like a what is it the
wrapping paper the wrap
the cardboard left over from the
wrapping paper the the tube
i've witnessed the normal you see oh
damn okay
i did it to one we had a guy that showed
up in ramadi a new guy
who's a great dude but he showed up and
he's a happy guy yeah
and he had a and he would smile all the
time right
uh we're talking private pile you know
and so i look at him go
hey you can't be walking around like
smiling like that you're a freaking team
guy you need to represent
we we are to ask you to bruiser not task
unit freaking smiley
so i played normal face with that guy
you know what i'm talking about
okay yeah and it was so funny because i
mean i was laughing
so hard because he could not even come
close to
not smiling and the more i did it and
the harder i hit him the harder i was
laughing he was laughing it was pretty
funny
one one normal face game i'm thinking
about was um
was uh your oldest daughter uh when she
was probably
probably seven maybe and we were at your
house
and uh on the pull-up bar in the garage
do you remember that no
and you're like get up there and show
life how many pull-ups you can do you
know so she gets up she cranks out some
pull-ups like awesome
and then you know maybe she wasn't even
seven because
she was way off the ground you know you
like lifted her up there to get there on
the
full-size pull-up bar so she's like four
feet off the ground
and uh and you were like and you're like
i will not catch you
and she's hanging on the bar like i will
not catch you she's like dad
dad you're like meanwhile you're your
hands are like right there ready to
catch you
yeah but she can't see him and i was
just like and
but you know what she actually was like
you you could see up initially she was
like dad yeah and then she was like
she just went like normal face and then
she dropped off you caught her it was
like yeah well you also have to train
your kids to deal with just
unknown terror
falling breaking broken bones
oh that's sorry way that
she turned out all right she's great
she's outstanding
uh yeah i you know it's a learning
process you know you learn you learn
about
you know you learn about controlling
your emotions life i've learned a lot
about parenting
i feel like uh with the kids practicing
or taking opportunities to practice
normal face 100
of the time is a good method it's a good
method
and it is a great thing like no joke it
is a great thing for a leader
to be able to control your emotions
because your emotions we already talked
about this if i'm panicking
if lace reports to me some news and i
panic he's gonna panic everyone's gonna
panic it's gonna be mayhem
if he sees me go all right all right got
it
you know it's like okay you know i've
had like at the muster
you know the musters uh there's there's
timelines and there's
you gotta be at a certain place at a
certain time you know and i've had jamie
come up to me you know
the so-and-so we don't have any of that
stuff yet it's like okay
and you can see that she's kind of
panicked about it you know we don't have
the labels for the whatever to pass out
stuff and i go okay we'll pass them out
tomorrow
and she's like okay you know just like
it's all good but that
that's an awesome thing man and that's
powerful i mean you and i were just
talking about this today right with some
some uh with echelon front stuff and uh
and our strategic growth
and and things that i was really
spitting up about and and
really stressing on you're like it's not
that big of a deal you know and that
that is that's something that is uh that
perspective you know when someone's
immersed
when someone is immersed in the details
of things and they're like it's the
weights bearing
down on them we're like man this isn't
gonna happen it's really easy to get
stressed out about that so
it's it's a powerful thing man yeah that
also
you know falls into uh some implied
intent
right of me and
leaving you with the impression that
something needs to be perfect because
well you know me like hey i like things
to be squared away and then all of a
sudden you've got something that's not
squared away
and you start trying to fix this problem
and it's you're investing more than it's
worth into the problem
and it's because i am giving you the
wrong implied intent that hey you know
what
if it's that much investment i don't
want you to make that much investment of
time into something that's
really not going to have a massive
impact strategically
so like i gotta do a better job of going
oh
you know let me know if something's a
struggle
where have i done this before um like
hey
if it's gonna cos this would be really
cool
to have it'd be really cool if we
executed this
but if we can't don't worry about it you
know don't
invest more than x amount of hours hey
go look at it for two hours if we can't
do it
you know we won't do it no factor it'd
be cool if we can but
let's not let's not lose sleep over it
whereas you know it's like once again
going back to gettysburg
what i need to remember is if
if general lee tells stonewall jackson
to do something he's going to freaking
do it and he doesn't care what
price he has to pay to accomplish that
mission well if i if i
mentioned to you like hey this would be
cool to have and you're like cool and
now the sudden you're paying the
ultimate price to
make something happen and you look up
you know three weeks later and you've
spent money and time and and it's like
you're like
i got it done or or maybe we can't
execute what your vision was it's like
okay cool don't worry about it it's like
that's not a good normal face
you know it's a little bit too much so
uh yeah it happens the final thing i'll
say about normal face is um
i love that my kids now have been
influenced i'll be like
we call it jocko normal face so when you
say
you know what we pretty much brand
everything as jock around here so we're
good i say
execute jocko normal face and they
they're like be smiling for a picture
they're like
boom it's on cue it's awesome
my one-year-old not so much yet but my
four-year-old six-year-old
they get some that's legit that's legit
um all right back to the book
chart number four evidence of so we were
on this whole thing talking about morale
and this is evidence of morale in
discussing the subject of morale with
visitors i often ask
and am asked what do you look for in a
unit or in order to gauge
the morale since morale is influenced by
so many factors
there are naturally many indications of
the state of morale
the things i note quickly in sizing up a
unit include
i'm going to burn through some of these
saluting dress
good housekeeping pride
pride i'll go into that one a little bit
are the men eager to show their
accomplishments do they point to their
unit's history with pride do they have
something good to sell and try and sell
it
participating in charities athletic
program and supportive teams and
athletic program enthusiastically
supported
is always a favorable indication of
morale church attendance
soldiers deposits and other savings
a man who saves his money each month is
banking on his future
and as well as it is usually a
well-adjusted and confident soldier
when there are many such soldiers in a
unit there is a depth of stability in
the organization
but commanders should not attempt to
coerce the men to participate in this
program
um you know just for for
for all leaders really this is probably
one of the things when i look back at my
military career
that i did a pretty horrible job of and
that was that
i never said all right guys here's what
you should do with your money
here's some here's some moves to make
you know
here's some things that you should do
here some things that you shouldn't do
so just if you're a leader especially if
you're a military leader
look when you're a mill when you're a
lot of kids that join the military
myself included
hey when i got to the teams and i was an
e4 in the teams i was the richest person
in the world
and you know i got that paycheck every
two weeks and i was ready to
rock and roll it was great
and you know i really wish
somebody along the way would have said
hey man that's cool
you know you're going to make whatever 5
000 this month
you know what i know you like to get
after it and go have a good time and you
should
and you should do that with four
thousand dollars not with 4
999 so
if you're in a position where you can
help people plan
their economic future please do that you
know what
it's funny you're actually saying that
because you you of of all the people i
worked with
in 13 years in the navy like you're the
only one that did that
and maybe not only like a on like a you
you didn't like have a presentation to
the entire task unit
you know maybe you could have done
something absolutely but you had a lot
of
direct interaction with a whole lot of
people and and helped
direct them and you know our influence
our encouragement to do something you
know
uh going the right route yeah i think to
your point i think
guys that were close to me i would be
like hey bro what you need to do is this
and so that's cool but it you know i
should have been doing it for everybody
and i didn't
and the reason is i didn't really care
about that stuff
honestly i didn't really think about it
i didn't really think about
that i just thought about hey we just
want to be good frogman and a good task
unit a good platoon
you know like that's it that's what
we're here for so
i should have been thinking a little bit
deeper about that but if you're in that
position
do it enlistment and reenlistment
records
a wall when such offenses are reasonably
easy to commit and the number of
offenses is low
it is indicative of high morale size of
sick call
court martial rates incidents and
accidents complaints about the inspector
general
this is another classic thing right so
complaints to the inspector general oh
sorry this isn't complaints to the
inspector general later in the book
leafy talks about
how you should be open and ready to
being inspected
like if you everyone's hates inspections
and doesn't want the commander to come
down
and he says you should be waiting for
that and it's very similar to
our attitude in ramadi which which i
absolutely stole
from the exo of the first the 506th
or sorry the yeah the exo the first the
five the opps officer from the
first the 506 um who
as soon as we got there there was an
investigation happening and he and i was
like yeah would he get investigated for
it he goes oh this that and the other
thing and
or this thing and i said oh this is that
how's that going to work out he goes i
love it when we get inspected
he goes i want them to come and inspect
and see what we're doing
and see what it's like down here and see
what it's like to live down here and let
them understand what's going on in the
front lines
and i i absolutely adopted that policy
and what's cool is what he says in this
book is you know
you why are you afraid of being
inspected you shouldn't have nothing to
hide
so if you're if you're afraid of being
inspected that's the problem
and let's fix the thing so that you can
be
open to being inspected you know we we
talked about that in extreme ownership
right leading up the chain of command
and how we invited our commander to to
come down and
see what we're doing and invite our
operations officer and their staff to be
there but
that's it's a complete opposite though
of what everybody else oh yeah
everybody else's mindset was like get
the boss man away
we don't want them around here we want
to be able to and
and what they wanted to be able to get
away with was like really minuscule
stuff like
uniforms around the camp like attendance
at meetings
little things that don't really matter
and and yet what we gained by having
them come out and visit us was
a deep understanding of our mission how
we were mitigating risk
what resources we needed um i mean it's
it's it's a
no-brainer and yet nobody does that
because they don't want the
the scrutiny of the big boss man the
wrong attitude
next section outside influence on morale
the factors
and indications of morale covered so far
concern things generally within the
control
of the commander but there are
influences on the morale of the soldiers
especially those
on duty in a far-off land which stem
from
attitudes of officials the press radio
commentators
and public at home the soldier should
feel that he is needed
and that his sacrifices are the of
immediate and long-range benefit to his
country his home his family and himself
he should feel that his unit is in is as
important to him as his family
that he is just as important to the unit
he will feel that importance as long as
the people at home
feel it he is sensitive to public
opinion at home and
because of good radio newspaper and male
facilities
is constantly aware of attitudes at the
home toward the importance of his job
that's an interesting perspective
compared to totally all
you know if we were reading newspapers
and watching tv
you know the particularly in 2006 the
iraq war it was just
constant negative coverage quagmire we
can't win
you know this is terrible uh we just had
to tune that stuff out
yeah and it's it's even more pronounced
now with social media
uh did we do we have social media was
there social media for us in
in in romania it was like myspace and
actually i do remarkably used to always
come back and get on facebook
so it existed yeah facebook existed but
it was not
i think it like myspace was still like
the dominant uh
uh 2006 echo where were we at social
media wise 2006. life is correct yes
just kicking it with like between my
space i thought myspace was
like a music something yeah you could
put music
so myspace was legit social media back
then
yes and before that too and before that
yeah
2007 you said 2006. what year did what
year did facebook come to prominence
oh i i don't know the exact year but
that's when you know when it was it was
rolling it was for sure but my space was
still going on as well
but there was a lot less people on all
these things you know what i mean i mean
now it's now
it's the now it it has replaced the
free iphone so you couldn't access it
with your phone you could only access it
through the
you know your your computer yeah that
was like barely
like right when pictures to the internet
started going like not all phones had
cameras and stuff like that
so bottom line we got to pay attention
to the influence on morale from
outside our organization pay attention
to it
this next section is called junior
officers
conferences and and
it says there are always many newly
commissioned officers fine officers in
the army
they have come from many sources some of
these young officers have demonstrated
outstanding
ability in combat others have not had
this experience few of them have had
the time or opportunity become fully
indoctrinated with the duties and
responsibilities required of an officer
the standards and responsibilities of an
officer are in many respects
more exacting and more difficult to
discharge in peace time than in combat
consequently
officers conferences should be conducted
for all junior officers
to review the duties and
responsibilities about it so what do i
what am i saying what he's saying is
that look you should meet with your
your subordinate leadership
and educate them and teach them and i
often ask this question to
clients
i say has anyone here had a person
that invested in them personally and
you know most of the time especially
when i'm talking to leaders most of the
time people will raise their hand and
say
you know oh yeah you know i've had i had
this person that took me under their
wing or
and i then i say well how does that how
did that make you feel
and obviously everyone says oh yeah that
makes you feel great makes you feel like
you can do well and it's a person that's
encouraging you
and then i say how many people are you
doing that for right now
and like there's less hands right and so
we take this investment of the people
that raised you
like the people that raised me and the
teams right what if i take that
investment i just hold on to it don't
give it to anybody else
that's horrible and it's not continuing
to grow
the capabilities of the community
there's
there's there's something deeper there
that i when he he said
roll some responsibility so you're
reviewing roles and responsibilities
with them and i think that's something
that
you know you the jocko brief that you
would give in
like the junior officer training course
when i was running training for two
years i ran training for all
seal officers are graduating from our
our basic training pipeline and
you came in we'd have you come in and
give the jackal brief and it was the
same thing that you briefed
to uh the task units and platoons going
through the work up and i think one of
the most
important parts of that was the rules
and responsibilities so i
it's great to mentor i mean you're right
people don't invest under people i agree
with that 100
but i think a lot of people don't know
how to mentor people
and what he's saying there i think which
is if you've got to make
their roles and responsibilities clear
and you broke down i mean it was it was
it was uh shooter you know your job
is to make things happen you know uh get
default aggressive
you have you have it listed out all the
way fire team leader you know
take your four guys lead your fire team
support your squad leader you had the
squad leader then you had the platoon
commanders
you had the assault chief you had the
you know assault force commander the
ground force commander
etc and that was a really powerful
document so much so that i've had
several um several uh
very successful seals including
good friends of yours who have reached
out to me and said uh hey can we get a
copy of that yeah
yeah yeah because it really it without
breaking that down
enables you to execute with confidence
if you know what your roles
responsibilities are
then you can actually step up and
execute with confidence and i think
that's a a really
people don't define that but you define
it a way where it was
easy to understand and enable people to
execute
and i think that's a great that's a key
thing to to mentor people on
one of the key parts of that when i
would get done talking about what the
roles and responsibilities of everyone
was
i would say okay now that you know your
roles and responsibility you also have
to understand
the person below you and the person
above you the chain of command you have
to understand what their roles and
responsibilities are
and if you have to you have to either
ascend or descend
into the situation where you can solve a
problem do their job as soon as you get
a problem solved
you can't get stuck there you have to
elevate yourself up to the next position
the last thing that i would start saying
to guys
once they were done with jhotsy and now
i'm talking to platoons
is i would say listen and i would
usually say this just to like the
headshed
i would say listen here's the roles and
responsibilities
i don't actually care who does these
things
but you better figure it out because
sometimes
you might have a platoon chief
that hadn't been in the teams for a few
years and he had some platoon
commander that had just gotten back off
deployment or you'd have uh
whatever the case may be maybe the lpo
just got done teaching assaults out at
you know at tradet
and now he's in the platoon or just got
back from land warfare so he's gonna
really know how to do that
job so i'd say listen it doesn't really
matter
which one you have now i'll tell you
basically and this is what i always say
basically
enlisted guys you're the tactical
experts you handle the problem that you
got
at hand officers you need to figure out
what the next move is going to be
and that that was the general thing but
then i'd say listen
if this officer like doesn't have any
experience whatsoever
and maybe the lpo is kind of badass and
the chief is
i'd say listen listen officer uh you
need to look to your chief
and he needs to elevate a little bit and
figure out what's going to do next
so and that well the reason that
happened was
because as i put more and more platoons
through training
i saw that some platoons they just
didn't they they had a mismatch they had
some
prior enlisted officer that was freaking
just a badass knew everything or they
had a
a a chief that was you know been out of
the loop for a while and so
okay but the lp like i said so
eventually
i would say listen i don't really care
how you guys break these up
but you have to know who's responsible
for what
and one man cannot do all these jobs
it's it's not possible for one man to do
all these jobs i've seen some badass
seals with tons of experience come
through here and they might be able to
pull it off or
on op or two ops and then something's
gonna happen and all of a sudden it's
going to be overwhelmed and other people
have to be able to back them up not to
mention
if somebody's doing all these jobs i'm
going to kill them and you better figure
it out
i remember the don't get stuck there in
all caps
get stuck there the slide uh
okay so the reason i wanted to cover
this section is because it says this
so we're talking about these junior
officer conferences
these conferences should be conducted by
commanders themselves and on an
informal basis lieutenants in separate
companies and detachments may be invited
to join groups from units commanded by a
field grade officer
groups should not be too large preaching
should be avoided i read this whole
section just so i could say that
preaching should be avoided
these conferences can well can well be
the means of improving the unit team
under the coaching of its captain the
unit commander these conferences may
consist of one-hour meetings he goes he
goes into some detail about how to do it
but the fact that he's saying look
you're not bringing people in there
to preach on how to do things you're
bringing there to educate to have
discussions
and he's got the whole topic of
discussions here military courtesies
personal standards
military discipline promotions unit
history esprit de corps
accomplishments missions uh troop
information morale self-education of
officers professional publications
responsibility for fun he's got
everything security classification use
misuse of
military vehicles so he basically it's
like tell
the guys what's going on that's what
he's saying you have to tell people
what's going on
and then he's got this commander's
checklist
for success and this we've already been
going for a while so this will probably
be the last thing we cover
every commander at every echelon should
maintain a continuing checklist to be
left for or given to
his successor to command
this checklist should contain items of
value that will assist the new commander
in becoming familiar with his command
more rapidly
than if he had on had to uncover the
same items over a period of time
such items must consist of one
significant strengths and weaknesses of
key officers and non-commissioned
officers in the command
boom isn't it weird
that we might be in charge of people and
know that we would have to turn this
over and not keep track of like whose
what strength and weaknesses are next
important policy matters announced by
senior commanders and not contained in
sop or directives
so you're tracking this stuff a good
turnover is the is
such an important thing to to do and
what i think is important about a
turnover
it's great to have it to turn over to
the next unit but what it does
is it forces you to actually think
through how you are operating
and when you force yourself to think
through how you're operating you
define it you refine it you codify it
and now it becomes stronger just like
when you
just like when you write down these
principles just like when you
formulate a standard operating procedure
and you just like when you teach a jiu
jitsu move or you write out how you do
any time that you study what you're
doing you will get better at it
and that's what this commander's
checklist for successors
i said successor it's for success it's
for someone that's going to take your
place
that you know what part of that too i
think is yeah that's self-analysis
you're talking about is like hey
what did we screw up what did we learn
from it i remember uh giving a turnover
one time
uh on a follow-on deployment and and
when the new unit came in
uh the the new seal unit taken over for
for us and
one of the one of the senior leaders was
like this is a great turnover you know
you guys are given here i
really this is one of the best tours
i've ever seen i'm like
why like why did you say that i just
kind of caught me off guard i was like
why do you why do you say that
he's like because you're telling us all
the stuff that you screwed up
and it was it's it's really you know
when you have a unit turning over
thinking like
people are coming in like get these
idiots out of here we're gonna take take
over even though we've been there for
six months
learning and i was like man how how are
you gonna
learn from us to continue the mission to
be more effective if we don't tell you
what we screwed up
but clearly he wasn't used to that and
most people weren't doing that and
um i think that thinking deeply about it
and if you care about the mission then
you want
you want the people to be successful i
mean we tried to set up the next seal
team
for sure you know steve ward and his
guys sir
yeah speaking of steve ward
he can be coming on the podcast sometime
real soon
uh names and personalities of
individuals outside the command with
whom it is necessary to associate and do
business areas of training
weaknesses within the command so
reporting the weaknesses like you just
talked about disciplinary matter
security manners
critical equipment shortages so that's
the that's that section
and here's the last thing we'll cover
vigilance
and by the way we're we are on page 13
right now
so yeah we're on page 13 of this book
there's 117 pages
one on page 13. a unit
operational readiness status status must
be ready for immediate employment at all
times regardless of how well
a unit has been trained the commander
cannot allow it to become lacks and let
down its guard
world war ii and the korean conflict
were started by surprise attacks on
sunday mornings
these surprises remind us that we must
be ready for anything
seven days a week 24 hours a day
we cannot relax our vigilance
in any way that would contribute to
disaster
so there you go like i said that is the
first
13 pages i'm always talking i'm only
two thirds of the way through my second
just getting our battle sniper
just getting up look i i'll get to the
rest of this
i'm sure i'll i'll cover this thing um
but it's just incredible to see how
these principles remain the same
over time and it's so
intriguing to uncover the roots
of hackworth and about face and thereby
the roots of me
and of you and of extreme ownership and
the dichotomy of leadership and
leadership strategy and tactics
there's a thread you can trace through
all these books
you got to know your roots and the
better the better you understand
yes history but the better you
understand the origin of ideas
and principles then the better you
understand those ideas and principles
themselves
and the better leader and person
you will become
crazy what do you think leif
i think that's outstanding i think
that's uh incredibly eye-opening and um
it's because i've read about face in
detail and and
you know i was flipping through my copy
this week
uh as i was kind of organizing stuff in
my my home office and
looking at just the you know the i
tabbed and underlying pages and
i actually had to i put packing tape
along the binder
because it's been so just um it's been
so
from overuse it's just been torn up and
and i had to reinforce it
um it's awesome to to understand where
colonel hackworth got some of these
ideas uh and
and look i'm sure you know i'm sure also
uh you know that these were learned from
from mentors you know and from
generations
uh as well but uh incredible stuff
definitely
making us better yes sir echo charles
yes
speaking of getting better mm-hmm
you you have any maybe i don't know
suggestions sure
now that you mention it actually i think
that's uh interesting your
that book that you finally located
it was like a little treasure hunt you
know the kind of guys who like they look
for treasure that might not even exist
you know that kind guy
that that was you she's like oh it
doesn't exist
see i'm saying you only got hints of it
through hackworth i have i have
access to all kinds of like i pay
you know these various websites that
offer all these
ancient pdfs i mean i got the most the
dumbest
subscriptions and i've been scouring
these things for years
nothing nada and how crazy is it
that the month that this version of
about face comes out
i freaking find this thing there's one
copy of it on amazon
and i have it it was meant to be i have
it
it's legit jocko got his treasure i have
the
arc yes which is the advanced reader's
copy
so so an advanced readers no i don't
have it of that book but an advanced
reader's copy
when a when a book is going to come out
they release
they'll print like they'll print how
many how many arcs do you think they
print in current days
i have no idea 100 000 no no advanced
reader copies
uh what are they called galleys oh i got
you i'm sorry yeah
how do you think they print like for
instance for extreme ownership i think i
got six and you got six
like that and then they printed some to
send to whoever
but we're talking absolutely yeah
absolutely less than 50 right less than
50.
so we were at the muster and a guy named
tobin came up
and he goes i have something for you and
he gives me like a brown paper bag
and this is just weird because it's hard
to even understand this it's
if you don't understand what an arc is
and understand how rare they are
that you know look you get like i love
first a dishes like i love first a dish
of about face but there's got to be a
hundred thousand of those things
floating around
right you know you might like the
first edition of extreme ownership you
know we always joke about it but there's
hundreds of thousands of copies of the
first edition of extreme ownership
there's only probably less than 50
arcs of extreme ownership
and same with the rest of all of our
books well so i'm at the muster
and this guy comes up to me and he goes
yeah i wanted to give you something and
i oh awesome appreciate it people give
us a lot of cool stuff all the time you
know
and he hands me this paper bag and i
open it up and there's a plastic
there's a book in plastic just a plastic
bag i pull it out and i look at it it's
in a
version of about face that i've never
seen before and it's thinner
than normal and i go what is this
and i pull it out of the plastic and
sure enough it's an
unedited advanced reader's copy
of about face signed
by david hackworth
this thing is priceless to me right
uh so he's out there i actually owe him
copies
of about face uh of this new version
but guess what else i'm sending him
later
arcs of extreme ownership
because they gave us about six each
i have all of mine i have mine as well
you want to know why
why do you have yours why did you keep
yours
uh i think some of them i intended to
send to people and they didn't get sent
and some of them i just thought would be
kind of cool you can hang on to
i only kept them first of all i didn't
know that it was a big deal
i didn't know that this is this whole
thing you know we didn't know what the
hell we were doing when it came to
writing
so we didn't know what the hell we were
doing so they sent us these things and
i'm like yeah whatever
well i didn't they're like you could
send them to you know the influencers
that you know
yeah oh i'm like and so what i'm
thinking is there's
misspellings in this there's some things
that we edited out
i said i don't want anyone to see this
and i just put them right in my
i put them in you know in like a drawer
somewhere and then
i don't know a few years later i started
as i actually as we started doing the
podcast
and i started getting more into getting
various books
and i always liked the first a dish
thing but then i realized at some point
that there was something
better than the first to dish and that
was the reader's
arc i got i got something better than
the reader's
arc and that is the uh
the word document manuscript oh yeah
which we got we've got the edit all the
edits like just the crazy edits that we
went through
you well that was crazy too because we
you were you in new york yeah you were
in new york when we wrote extreme
ownership
and we had to edit that thing and i
remember spending
four hours on the phone going through
final edits we'd be like all right pages
page 64. hey you said this what do you
think and you'd be like oh yeah we need
a chance you know
so we would just sit there and manually
go through
for hours on the phone these stupid
edits
you know and what's what's interesting
is and we were talking about this the
other day there was
one of the last edits that we did we
kind of got out the freaking
the clenched fist of editing and just
started cutting stuff
you know we started getting rid of stuff
that was pretty
that was pretty cool you know it'll be
interesting to see uh you know
i think particularly if you think about
decades from now and what that might be
like
a friend of mine showed me you know
obviously that stuff becomes quite
valuable to collectors and the people
that know
you know it's meaningful to people that
it has uh that understand the value of
what it is and how rare it is and
uh a friend of mine had shown me a copy
of of a it was a biography of stonewall
jackson
and he was like he handed it to me i was
old and kind of brittle i felt like it
was going to fall apart
opened up and it's this g patent dang
it it was patton's personal copy totally
annotated like noted like all the notes
and the margins
uh you know something that general
patton went through
and and knowed it was pretty pretty
awesome that is awesome i have
all the books that i've covered in the
podcast with all the tabs and notes and
red lines and
highlights and everything and it's
freaking cool
to sit there and go back because i'll go
back and look at a book
that i you know i already covered on the
podcast i'm like i didn't even come
close to getting
like everything out of this that i need
to get out of this
you know with the old breed especially
the early podcast where we would
not they weren't as long and and now i
look and i go man
and go we could dig right back into that
thing
right back into that thing you did you
did speaking of pat you did boars i knew
it as well which
i gave you that copy you gave me that
copy yeah it's signed
by leif babin not by general pat
not quite as valuable a copy of war as i
knew it
and it is signed by leif babin and i am
damn proud of that
disappointing yeah well you posted the
copy that i originally gave you of about
face the other day
and you know it had my uh my
you because you made me sign it you were
like hey bro you need to sign this and i
was kind of like whatever
whatever what are you talking about i
was like bro he gives my book you need
to sign the book and i'll put a date in
it you know yeah
i'd never give presents to anyone and so
or gifts of any kind and i i've never
given anything to anybody really
have i ever given you anything echo
books oh yeah so i yeah i've given you
some books
i just gave you the i just gave you
about face yeah all right so anyways
but when you asked me i was kind of i
don't come from the background of giving
things in the in the in the on the
scale of gift givers like taco is if you
know if 10 is greatest one is the least
um choco is like point zero
two jamie cover and move cochrane
sent like my sent my oldest daughter
flowers for her birthday
whatever a year ago or something like
that from me
and my daughter did not even remotely
believe it for one second yeah she was
like who did you get to send me flowers
and i was like
uh oh jamie i can't lie
can't lie to my daughter uh so there you
go
pretty cool so yeah i did sign your book
and and then we just
we just re we re-enacted the signing of
the book
and i put the same thing so there you go
all right
echo charles speaking of getting better
yes you said oh then you you started
asking us
do you have any more questions no for
the crew here no
no that was more of my that was my
takeaway that's how i was regarding this
book the whole time like that's your
little treasure that you found
finally after your journey you know i
wonder what's going to happen now like
once this comes out
is is stackpole books gonna reissue it
or is jocko publishing somebody's gonna
dig their like grandfather's copy out
and uh there's gonna be nine of them on
the internet i'll buy them
750 bucks yeah yeah i'll buy them you
know how much
uh uh old hardcover copy of about faces
like they were on yeah they were on
amazon the other day you know you can
buy it they're like 200 bucks yeah
200 i have 20 copies
all right there we go all right yeah
okay all right getting better right
we're on the path okay
we're getting better even if we're good
by the way like you know
what do you call we're maintaining
vigilance yes big time
for sure um but anyway on our road
of improvement for improvement
this is what we're doing okay we're
working out every day all right life not
to put you too much on this
on the spot but you work out every day i
try to
okay so that was my answer too which you
know that that's a non-answer by the way
because there's varying levels of try
not to say that that's uh
you know yeah listen uh the the goal is
work out every day
um sometimes i achieve that on a you
know on a weekly
basis cool i knocked it out other times
you know
life gets in the way but uh every uh
every the days that i miss workouts it's
it's deeply regretful
and when you don't do that it's it's a
problem yeah and and i actually got to
kind of be honest with
where if that's the goal like for a real
goal you know to work out every day that
is a good thing
as opposed to you know like hey i'm
going to try to work out this week
you know there's a difference is what
i'm saying so okay well there's a big
difference between i'm going to try and
work out
every day and i'm going your workout
every day yes sir
yeah and then if you want to talk about
just keeping it real
yeah and as far as better and worse goes
for sure for sure
anyway so when we work out every single
day oh is this a conversation we're
gonna have with life and
jocko is that what's happening because
that's what i'm feeling i think it's
i think it's wildly unnecessary to have
it with you at this time
you know i'd rather your joints
will jam you up if you let them i'm not
going to talk too much about this right
now
i don't even really appreciate that i
don't think we should
anyway i don't think we should even
think about it that much right
at all joint should be a thing you don't
think about you seem to say good point
i see where you're going with this and i
like it yeah what should we be thinking
about
gains obviously yes yes so let the
joints just be joints you see i'm saying
anyway so the joints are
uh monopolizing your attention here's
what you do boom choco fuel joint
warfare
these are for your joints for sure super
creole oil for your joints i take
both every day for sure every day right
you know what actually
i i had i had an eye surgery recently
and so i had to stop taking it for a
little bit and like
i know it it what's crazy about those is
when you stop taking them like
why'd they stop taking why did you die
they didn't actually tell me to but like
i i just
you know i just uh i just didn't take
them for like three or four days you
know
oh cause you were like laid up and
whatever not really laid up but just
just like i i i i got out you're off
your routine
i was off my recovery yeah okay and uh
and it was it was
like i feel it i definitely feel it and
uh and there's
it's uh it ain't just
it it's real it really is man you feel
the joints uh
and and i think both both krill and john
warf are awesome
yeah and then it just keeps you kind of
boom on the path in that way so boom
yeah don't worry about joints anymore
you don't have to is what i'm saying
anyway another thing you don't want to
be worrying about is getting sick
because that's one of those things let's
face it we're not every day like
fighting to boost our immune system or
something like this
maybe we are maybe not i know i am not
consciously
okay so when you wake up wake up oh yeah
well
yeah well you brought it up you brought
it up you brought it up taco
so at 4 00 am whenever you wake up are
you like okay let me get this immune
boosting scenario cracking right now
part of my routine
it's consciously part of your routine
constantly part of my routine i have my
supplements lined up when i go
in to brush my teeth in the morning it
doesn't count i do what i'm supposed to
do totally doesn't count
when i go and brush my teeth at night i
do what i'm supposed to do that includes
both brushing my teeth taking my
supplementation and flossing which i
never flossed until i joined the navy
they told me to floss i started flossing
all right cool
cool do you take supplements pre-workout
yes
yep what are you taking i take three
super crow
three joint warfare and vitamin d oh
like for the pre-workout you mean like
for the workout
but it's different not for the workout
no but prior to yes
i do yeah is that what you're asking
yeah like is that when you take them
rather than do you
take something before the workout for
the workout there's two different
questions
i'll slam some discipline go use it for
the workout but i definitely uh
yeah usually the no it's it's good i
just
i i just was curious yeah i i do i take
it every morning
it's part of my routine and then at
night
and we had this whole guy i do not want
to talk about this right now
but echo did not have a routine and
therefore he would miss
yes just like you just said life you got
out of your routine yeah
and you miss like that's a real thing
set up a routine
follow it yeah and that's and then vary
it sometimes to make sure their
terrorists aren't tracking you
all good good side note yeah good idea
yeah
and when you fall out of the routine
work out or taking the
you know the supplements supplementation
as we like to say um that can sort of
become the routine you see insane or
part of it
it is not even thinking about it all
right well anyway back to the immune
system
thing so technically you're just like
hey i'm gonna go ahead and take
this stuff so i don't have to worry
about my immune system kind of thing
you're not consciously look i'm not
splitting hairs here but it's
significant
it's significant so i think anyway
immune system my ultimate point with
that is you don't have to worry about
that either
no vitamin d three i called
choco fuel and cold war boom the combo
now you're really not worrying about it
anyway also after you're done not
worrying about these things you don't
have to worry about now let's start with
the conscious stuff okay we got
discipline
right good really good helps you think
i would say think but here's what i
noticed about this about this one
where it's one of those ones where you
know how like when you go somewhere like
you always want to have a little drink
going
whether it be water or whatever i think
this is the best thing for that
i agree maybe not before we go to bed or
whatever but
yeah obviously that's it yeah anyway
yeah i saw you
pound that i watched you i just crushed
two of these
dude this is my new this you were
notably smarter this entire podcast
i noticed it but are you saying the bar
wasn't very high
i gotta say i am not a sour apple sour
apple guy like i i
if i was a kid eating jolly ranchers
like i would
leave the sour apples there unlike jp to
know uh
sour apple sniper is legit yeah that is
it's awesome uh my family actually is
all over the map uh
i mean don't get me wrong jack savage oh
is dax average or go to
dak savage has been my go-to for a while
but uh
uh but sour apple sniper is uh is
awesome and uh i gotta give
i gotta give jp credit for that's legit
that's awesome
yeah those are kind of with your family
on that one where here's what i found
and this might be the case for all this
it's the only reason i'm mentioning it
so remember yeah when it first came out
i was like man this is the best one
a little bit better than jacques palmer
what straight up nope
and you know what's funny is people like
say it to me like you're all
in either one of two ways one is like
you know i kind of like this apple
sniper like they they kind of ashamed to
tell me
and then the other one's like shot rap
sniper's way better yeah yeah that's
what you get
yeah yeah so but i did find out there's
like a deeper game within the game
it was it was probably better it was
probably better
because it was new straight up because i
kept pounding them sweet yeah here and
i'll tell you something else just just
to
just uh people might be thinking about
this
i want to drink this stuff all day long
uh i want to drink
jocko palmer i wanna drink it all day
long but it does have caffeine in it 95
milligrams caffeine
so i don't want to drink seven
discipline goes so we are making a
discipline go
type drink that doesn't have any
caffeine but and it's uh it's going to
be a ginger ale
flavor a ginger flavor and i've already
approved the
taste of it okay and it's really it's
really good and what's cool about it is
it's it's on the sweet side i have to
admit
this sour apple sniper kind of started
making me like
yeah started leaning me a little bit
more sweetness so the ginger
is it's it's nice sweet but here's what
makes me think about it is that night
you know you get done with eating your
tomahawk steak
sure and you have a little sweet tooth
but you're too full
for a mulk because let's face it we
could go just straight to malt get your
dessert on
but you're a little bit full the
tomahawk was bigger than normal okay but
you want to have a little
a little sweetness yeah crack it open
boom there you go
decaf yeah decaf so we're working it
okay good
well there it is there's also
disciplined powder by the way life you
mentioned pre-workout that's my go-to
pre-workout too the discipline powder
with water most of the time we actually
were talking about this like that i
the the discipline powder is awesome
what flavor do you like lemon lime
dang it legit because
jocko palmer powder is freaking legit
the other day it was super easy here in
socal and i made
i mean i mixed up a picture like you do
in
like they do in the like they do in
texas bro a big
glass pitcher i filled it up with ice
put the jackal palmer in there
and it was a huge amount and i just
drank that thing all day it was
freaking awesome so get your jackal
palmer on oh yeah agree
my you know what you know recommendation
what's cool about that i think with the
powders you can
you can dilute a little bit you know so
you can you can you can have the entire
you know i have a problem
like many americans the problem that
many americans myself included have
is simply stated more is better
so so i like mixed these things what's
these things called
echo these these glass things travel
mugs
no wait it would have been the class a
tumbler so i get these tumblers and you
know
let's face it you only need two scoops
of discipline into one of these tumblers
well in your case but i will no doubt
put i will no doubt put
four scoops in there more is better and
it doesn't need it but you know you just
think i might as well just get that
extra little later
i know it's going to be a good time at
the muster when we've got a tumbler up
there on the stage
mixed up and you get you're drinking at
the bottom of it you're just getting all
powder
sure let's get some
[Music]
you know okay let's just talk about that
for one second okay the early musters
where we were disorganized
on the back end we we we had a lot of
stuff to learn and so we would sleep not
at all but i remember the new york
monster we slept one hour one night
if that and the next night we got like
an hour and 45 minutes
and everyone says you're cognitive if
you sleep less than five
hours it's like you're drunk have you
ever heard that
if you sleep less than five hours it's
like you're drunk you're a
hazard to humanity meanwhile you and i
are
up on stage for seven straight hours
that day
answering questions you know people are
coming at us with all kinds of
leadership problems
and i didn't hear you up there going
i'll tell you what yes
like how do they come up with that who's
the scientist that says like well
you're drunk if you slept less than you
know and look i'm not trying to get
crazy here and you know for everyone
that freaks out about this
and discipline equals freedom field
manual i explained sleep is necessary i
get it
uh it's good for you it's healthy i tell
everyone get as much sleep as you can
i'm totally down for the cause
sleep it's great but to go and say
hey if you don't get eight hours you're
a drunk you're you're an equivalent of
being drunk
think about in ramadi man we're
launching on cop falcon you know we're
going into
south central ramadi neither you or i
had slept at all
yeah we were up we've been up for 24
hours at that point and we're launching
an
operation where we're going to be out on
the battlefield for 48 hours
so it's like what do you do like you you
just power through
like you just btf there's i mean you
know
when we when we got into position and i
got security set like i tried to take
her down for an hour you know just to
try to get a
get some shut eye wow i could while i
was dark before the sun came out we knew
we were going to get it on as we get
attacked but
life requires that you're going to have
some sleepless nights and you got to be
able to get some and
um and you can get some more if you have
some a little bit of discipline on a
little bit of discipline
we had some discipline go on uh the cop
falcon off would have been that much
better i think
ramadi would have been secured a lot
quicker
i uh i think the drunk reference
comparison was like when you're driving
yeah okay so now they take oh
the number of accidents that happen from
people that are drunk to the number of
people that fall asleep at the wheel
okay cool got it in a way
yeah i got it you know in a way being
like
overly tired driving could then again i
don't know could be worse everybody's
different because people
you get the point where you can control
it like being drunk because this you
know let's face it
sometimes when people are drunk behind
the wheel they get like
more daring and aggressive so they'll
you know it's less that like
oh they're drunk and they drifted
you're saying it's their attitude more
than their motorcycles eating
their yeah this and then sure a lot of
times you can't react as fast as you're
talking about lack of sleep so it's kind
of like
leaving nylon at uh at like
two o'clock in the morning yeah the red
bull run yeah
and had we had some discipline go back
then obviously would be that much better
we would have been no [ __ ]
away we'd have been good to go you know
so hey you know
again not to split hairs but you know
these things sometimes
you know you add a little nuance little
explanation they start to make more
sense
that's what it was what i think that's
what i already what else we got
chocolate white tea war your kid milk
mulk what else anything else
but a bunch of cool stuff yeah and by
the way you can get them at
origenmaine.com you can also get them at
the vitamin shop
and yes you can get them at a little
place called
wawa in florida in the virginia area
and by the way if you're in those areas
go get some yeah go into a wawa
clean it out yeah it's a different
situation like i mentioned before is it
because
look online even if you got to go i mean
vitamin shops not as convenient
storage like they're not everywhere or
whatever but it's a different situation
you got to go on there you got to make
it a point to stock up and all this
stuff right now you can just grab one on
the go it's way different here's what
here's what the folks at wawa are
wondering
who wants this stuff should they should
they put it in every store in america
that's what they're wondering or every
store that they have
if you want to you can support the cause
just clean them out
let them know we want yes we want it is
in demand it is in demand as far as that
goes
all right also yes okay you you
mentioned origin main.com that's where
you get
the can get jocko fuel which is all of
this stuff
also at urgentman.com is jiu jitsu stuff
geez rash guards
some shirts on there and also of course
jeans and boots
american made delta denims back in the
game by the way if you're
waiting on delta jeans they're back and
we got more denim
so we're good very good also i got my
lincoln boots getting broken in right
now nice they're legit
nice what do you mean lincoln boots
that's what that's the one with the toe
cap
oh that's the best that's the model did
you did you request the toe cap
or did you just get it from pete he just
sent you what do you want yeah
you gotta watch out dude pete is sneaky
pete
tries to tries to impose his will
on you like i i was like no i don't want
to toe cap
i don't you know i was like i don't know
don't give me the link just give me the
regular ones and he goes yeah yeah yeah
and what shows up at my house the
regular ones and a pair of lincolns
and i'm like bro he does he does these
little sneaky things
and he thinks he's getting one over on
you that's the thing
pete we're tracking bro we are tracking
he likes to do that i like the toe cap
it's good oh here's another thing he did
to me
i said hey bro i wear white geese
i wear white geese so you know this was
pretty early
into the whole thing merger
and he's like he's like oh yeah yeah
definitely what does he send me
and i said you know what in a stretch
maybe a black g why is that by the way
tradition it's the tradish
the first key he sends me no [ __ ] it's
blue
the only color i said hey look just
don't send me a blue gee because i i
wear a white ghee
right maybe i get it black you know what
the
you know what the most popular color
ghee is in the like just
which means yes in the world black yeah
it's black
yeah which which to me white was the
tradition that's what we do
we keep it your dish but let's face it
what's the facts the facts is
everybody wants to be a ninja
that's what it is they're having a
little yeah it makes sense
for me i want to be uh charles bronson
in the movie the mechanic
they're they're wearing white geese and
that's what i always refer back to in my
time i do
some of my training partners and uh
instructors
i've uh i've sent them as a gift uh
a origin rift ghee and the we are i
think we're six for six for black
yeah the black riffs yeah did you
request white
uh no no i i said tell me what you want
oh
okay oh yeah yeah there you go send me a
black one
yeah well that's that means a lot coming
from todd white
right because he's an artist he
understands the color
palette yeah you know what i'm saying
he's down there thinking what will look
good the i gotta say though on the for
the rest we've got uh we've also got
six out of six like outstanding reviews
as well
the rift is ridiculous yeah yeah it's
it's kind of junk not the ghee but the
situation because
you know a lot of us we have more than
just the one ghee you know so you
do the rift now all those other geese
sort of seem obsolete a little bit you
know like you don't put that dumb thing
back
on the old ones you know yeah that's
just how
it's like the new iphone when you get
the new iphone you're kind of like
this is all well it happened with the
iphone
uh not the 6 the 11.
no seriously the the iphone 6 you're
like oh you know it's okay and the
battery would run out the pictures
sucked and all this stuff
i was with i was with joe rogan like
last year and we were
we were taking pictures of the sunset
while we were hunting
his picture looked freaking he had an
iphone 11. it looked brilliant filled
with colors it looked like a freaking
national geographic picture
because we were taking a picture of the
sunset so you could see like the
mountains and then there was the horizon
and then there was a sky all beautiful
colors
my picture just looked like black on the
bottom and white on top
and then i just said i'm an idiot they
call that dynamic range
yeah it's a photographer what you're
saying is you don't realize
that you don't realize how good
something can be until you actually try
out the new one
and i think uh it liked asking a bruiser
i was like i thought we were pretty good
my first task in it
until we were in bruiser like actually
we weren't that good basking in
bruiser's better
and the rift is definitely like that
yeah you're like okay i'm not running
anything else
it's kind of it's kind of a game but
pete i don't think he's sneaky i think
well he's sneaky
but i think he's like smart he's in that
way because
i was with you with the difference yeah
that's what i'm saying i agree with
these different so
the the the ghee right so
i wasn't down for the other color geese
either all i had was white for a reason
bro like i'm like because you're one of
my black belts
one of the people yeah yeah it was true
but here's what pete was thinking is my
uh hypothesis
he was like look i get it they like the
white gee that's the tradition can't
argue with that but they just haven't
felt
the power the pleasure of the black he
they just if i can get them to somehow
feel what i'm feeling about that okay
so he'll give you a free one you'll be
like i can't wear this thing and you put
it on you're like
i feel like a [ __ ] you can't make it
maybe i am a ninja after that
pete is successful boom did that with
the boots for you
pete gets uh some level of credit for
his sneakiness but
just so you know pete roberts listening
to this i'm
i'm seeing your moves bro yes sir i'm
seeing your moves
you're not getting anything by me i get
it you know keep it up pete yeah
yes 100 also what do we have oh okay
choco has a store
it's called jackal store we got some new
stuff on there by the way
hoodies are back in by the way that was
a big idea look at this
for winter time yes sir yes yeah you
know the last
last season you know when we got
sweatshirts made
oh yeah we're trying to uh you know
tighten things up a little bit
you know what i'm pretty stoked about at
the jocko store is the board shorts
yes sir yeah those kind of are coming
for fall winter too which is kind of off
beat but hey man hey we're happy it's a
process okay look i've been asking for
them for
three and a half years so i'm glad we're
i'm glad they're there here we go
yep exactly right yeah they're pretty
good they run a little bit loose though
the board
shorts a little bit loose and run that's
good
that's good for me yeah yep there you go
yeah
i don't you got to squeeze the tree
trunk legs into uh
you can't be doing the skinny jeans
skinny board shorts it doesn't work yeah
that's good
yourself a little bit of room um yeah
and some
stuff on there uh coming up too as well
so if also we have an email list on
there if you want to sign up
to get notified what you call
notifications for new stuff but you
didn't know the word notification
is that what just happened no i was
about to say like if you want a notifier
you know how you use the wrong word for
the wrong
context anyways what do you call dotting
my
eyes crossing my teeth
while you're on this path that's where
you do it
also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already on your
uh i uh itunes and wherever you listen
to podcasts
yeah this is not the only podcast we
have by the way we also have jocko
unraveling
which i do with daryl cooper martyr made
fame
of martyr made fame there you go daryl
grounded podcast which is about jiu
jitsu warrior kid podcast
we got some a little bit of time i'm
gonna
squeeze in some grounded some warrior
kid podcast in the near future
uh we got a youtube channel and if you
want to subject yourself to
videos where echo charles has complete
creative control to make everything blow
up everything catch on fire
then you can check it out and the only
and if as long as it's a video less than
five minutes there may be cool stuff if
it's a long video that actually would
be nice to see some effects in they
won't be there so
okay anyway yes and you can see what
life looks like if you're not
um or if you're intrigued by his
texas batman um persona
voice wise appropriate way to put it
we got something called psychological
warfare it's an album with tracks
that i talk to you about overcoming your
moments of weakness you can get that on
any mp3 platform out there in the world
it was the number one selling spoken
word
album for 11 months on itunes
that makes sense it makes sense because
it's not just artistically
uh good or whatever it's effective
functionality how many spoken word
albums are there
tons of questions yeah there's thousands
i will say this
there's something in the universe where
sometimes you know how you're like
if your bluetooth on your phone just
randomly sticks up with your car
and like at my kind of darkest or lowest
moments like it seems to like
sync up and just randomly select and
it's jocko's voice and it's usually at
max volume everything happens
yeah you have that moment of weakness
creeping in or you're probably heading
to the donut shop when
that thing comes on uh also flip side
canvas
my brother dakota meyer flipside
canvas.com he's making
graphic representations of the path and
other
basically cool stuff i know you just
we got some comments bad ass stuff
coming from flipping which one do you
guys
uh we've got uh we've got good
check and uh we've got this one equals
freedom we got all kinds of we got
default aggressive
routes um and uh we've got uh a bunch of
posters
as well of the muster and of echelon
front you know impacting
with troopers you didn't get a poster
that had like
an outstretched hand on the cliff and
another hand going to it and it says
underneath
teamwork
you know those posters like the freaking
uh
yeah those posters at flipside canvas
we do not sell those posters we sell
posters that are that can only be
described
with one word legit
the posters are legit and dakota and
mandy on the team are awesome
awesome to work with we got some books
about face first to dish
with the forward by me which is just
freaking an honor to be able to do we
got the code
the evaluation the protocol leadership
strategy and tactics
field manual warrior kid
way of the warrior kid one two and three
by the way
way the warrior kid four you can
pre-order it right now
it's called way of the warrior do you
know what the name of the new way the
warrior kid is you might know yes
do you know what it is i do not it's
called the way of the warrior kid
four field manual
premise is uh the last day of school you
know mark's been having some hard years
but this but now he's kind of getting
dialed in
last day of school a kid comes up to him
and says hey you know i've never really
talked to you before
and i i notice you know you wear that
warrior kid i see you doing
pull-ups with your friends and this kind
of kid's kind of shy and he says
i really wanted to be a warrior kid like
you
and now it's too late because i'm moving
away
and i you know i just i wish i could
have hung out with you
and so uncle jake shows up and
and mark tells uncle jake about this and
says you know hey this guy i feel really
bad this kid's moving away he wanted to
be a warrior kid he was too shy to say
anything
and he's you know wanted me to help him
but i don't know what i could do
and uncle jake says i know what you can
do write him a field manual on how to be
a warrior kid
so there you go and uh it's the same
let's say shape and size as the
discipline equals freedom
field manual you may notice some
similarities when it comes to the
layout just the layout of the cover
it's funny john bozak sure
the artist the designer
whenever i say like a good idea he
always says i think you might be onto
something there
so i was explaining the cover like boy
your kids are believing he is
i think you might be on to something
there so yeah so way the warrior kid
four
is available miking the dragons
which has been described as the greatest
children's book ever written
that's what i've heard sure i mean i'm
not look i wrote it i don't want to you
know
be out of line here but apparently a lot
of people think
a lot of people think a lot of people
think
and the discipline equals freedom field
manual oh by the way there's a new
version of that coming out
you know what it's called mark one mod
one you know what that means
kind of yeah some cameras are like that
so i go mars one mark two mark three so
this is the first
modification to the original the
splinters freedom field manual
there's a bunch of new pages in there
wrote about a bunch of new things
so you can check that out and then of
course
there's a little book called extreme
ownership that i wrote with my brother
leif babin
and the follow-up to that book which is
called
the dichotomy of leadership the things
that we you heard us talking about today
if you want to see how to take those
things and apply them to what you're
doing in life
whether it's your business whether it's
your first responder whatever you're
doing
whatever you're doing if you're
interacting with other human beings
get to the source extreme ownership and
the dichotomy leadership
ashland front what what's up with
echelon front life what do you got
got a lot going on with echelon front
working with leaders all the time uh you
know as we talked about it just been
phenomenal to watch them particularly
through these tough times of you know
some
some economic turmoil through coveted
lockdowns and
and unrest across riots across america
et cetera like
it's been uh it's been awesome to see
companies take and apply those
principles and
uh so we've got got some great stuff
going on echelon for i think
particularly for ef online our
we have we have uh redesigned that
thanks to
the great echo charles who put some
mastery behind that uh for
our uh our landing page and design and
setup and uh we've
streamlined the process of login on that
thing and we've got troopers from i
think
i'm glad you get the great echo charles
i seem to end up with the average echo
charles over here
i think we're reckoning uh happy with
that is that a good joke
cool i think we have 46 countries uh
around the world representing right yeah
ef online what we're doing is we're
look our goal our mission at echelon
front is to teach the leadership lessons
that we learned on the battlefield that
we translate into
everyday business everyday life how to
lead
how to lead up and down the chain of
command doesn't matter if you're it
doesn't matter if you're the the ceo
or a frontline person that's not in
charge of anyone
when you are interacting with other
human beings you are in a leadership
position
you can you can do things to improve the
mission you can do things
that will improve your station in life
go to efonline.com we got courses about
this stuff
we do live training all the time if you
want to ask me a question
if you want to ask leif a question about
something he said today go on there
go to efonline.com for that
we are standing by to help spread the
word
we have the muster the muster is there's
only one this year
due to covid and
there is going to be in dallas texas
december 3rd and 4th
i just did a gig and
you know there's 500 people there
there's social distancing happening
so it's going to be something like that
um
we'll take precautions but the musters
on yeah the mustard is on we're
super excited to meet with troopers it's
been such a bummer
to have to have cancel two of them yeah
uh but i'm really excited to have this
one here in december dallas
here's another another bummer is that
since we canceled the other two
most people at the other two transferred
their tickets to
this one which means it's gonna sell out
like they always do
so if you wanna come just try and
register early it's extremeownership.com
and we also have ef overwatch from
day one we've had people asking us hey
where can we get people that understand
these leadership principles
eventually we started this company ef
overwatch go to efoverwatch.com we got
mike cirelli
at the helm if you heard him on podcast
him and george randall they they geek
out
about hiring and and getting people into
companies
taking leaders military leaders that
understand these principles
train in these principles and then show
up at companies and help
you lead your company to victory go to
go to
efoverwatch.com and if you want to
help service members active service
members retired
service members their families gold star
families
around the world then you can check out
mark lee's
mom she has a charity organization
mama lee if you want to donate or get
involved then you can go check out
america's mightywarriors.org
and if you're a masochist
if you like pain and you just want more
of my discordant
declarations or if you want more
punishment in the form of echoes
disoriented diatribes or you want to
get some more alef's prolonged
proclamations
then you can find us on the interwebs
leif is on twitter at leif babin he's on
instagram which echo will
only refer to as the gram
at real life babin and he's on facebook
at lake babin and of course echo is
at echo charles and i am at jacob
willink and thanks to
general bruce clark for your service to
our great nation
for your leadership and guidance that
continues
to have an impact today and thanks to
all of our service men and women who are
out there
leading and also having an impact in the
world by protecting
our freedom and of course
to police and law enforcement and
firefighters
and paramedics and emts and dispatchers
and correctional officers and border
patrol and secret service
and all other first responders thank you
for protecting and keeping us safe here
at home
and to everyone else out there remember
these lessons from general clark
remember that the commander must be a
model soldier he must master the
technique of war he must expand and
improve his knowledge he must exhibit
daily stamina and courage and above all
you must set the example
and you set the example every day
by going out there and getting after it
until next time this is leif
and echo and jocko out